This is Jocko podcast number
one 51 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good Evening
Echo. Good evening. And
we haven't done a Q and a for a while
and we're going to roll into a Q and a.
And normally
quite frankly,
normally the Q and A's when
we show up for the Q and A's,
there's a little bit of a different
atmosphere we'll say, right sir?
A little bit of levity in the room.
Everything's like, you know, hey,
we're not going to talk about war.
We're not going to be reading
about men being wounded or killed.
We're not going to be reading about
some atrocity and hearing what people go
through. We're going to be
answering questions and there's,
there's a little bit more
just lightheartedness to
the whole thing. Usually.
Sometimes it goes a little bit, you
know, one way or the other. But this is,
there's just a little bit of a different
situation in the recording room right
now because we just did a,
uh,
and this is kind of surprising cause we
just did a warrior kid podcast and in
the warrior kid podcast I answer
questions from kids for Uncle Jake.
And those are all, you know, kind of just
little neat little kid questions. Hey,
our cheeseburgers,
good for you and what do I do?
And I'm nervous that a Jujitsu tournament
and what do I do when I can't remember
how to Spell Mississippi?
You know,
just like these nice little kid questions
and they're fun. And yet, you know,
I treat them seriously because kids
have serious questions and when you're a
little kid, those are real
problems. Those aren't,
we laugh at him now you're laughing
at him like, well the Mississippi one.
That's right, you're over there
laughing at the kids' issues.
But then when I started doing a little
while ago and I started telling these
stories from the perspective of
Uncle Jake when Uncle Jake was a kid.
And some of those are a little bit more,
they're a little bit more serious,
but there's always a very big lesson
to be learned because my goal with the
stories from Uncle Jake is that kids
can end up understanding how uncle Jake
kind of formulated his values as a man.
And we've talked about a bunch of
different ones of those. Uh, but anyways,
the one that I did today,
and what's interesting is all these
stories are kind of based on their based
loosely around, around things that
I've experienced. And this is very,
some of them very loosely,
some of them not so loose on things
that I've actually experienced,
things that I went through
because I'm not uncle Jake,
but I have some similar experiences that
uncle Jake has had along the way in any
ways today.
I wanted to make the point to kids that
the decisions that they make in their
life are, they have a big impact, right?
And if you make little
decisions when you're a kid,
you start making bad decisions.
When you're a little kid,
those bad decisions eventually add up.
And if you make good decisions,
those decisions will add up and you'll,
in the one case,
you'll end up with good things.
If you make good decisions,
if you make bad decisions,
you'll end up in a bad situation.
And I told this story from Uncle Jake's
perspective about uncle Jake's best
friend when he was growing up.
And it was a kid named Jeff
and they were best friends.
They did everything together and they,
they played and they did practical jokes
and they laughed and had a great time.
And eventually Jeff starts
making some bad decisions.
He gets in trouble in class and he gets
in more trouble than he gets suspended
from recess and just, and then
the next thing you know, he starts
really going down a bad path and
starts using drugs and alcohol.
And eventually, and again, I, this
is a long, this is not a long story,
but it's probably takes about 10 minutes
to tell on the podcast on the warrior
could podcast.
And then eventually I leave high school,
we graduated from high school and I kind
of talk about seeing him and this is
what's true. Like so this is true,
so this is based on true story.
I had a best friend when I was a kid.
His name was Jeff. He was an awesome kid.
He was funny. And what? He's one of those
kids, I've talked about this before,
like some kids, they have a
little spark to them. Yeah,
and it's not a lot is very few kids,
they have this little spark.
They've got this little thing
about them that you go, okay,
that person has something now that
spark doesn't guarantee anything.
In fact,
that spark can be a problem because that
spark and catch fire and it can be an
uncontrollable fire or it can be a fire
that can be used to fuel and grow and
create awesome things and you don't
really know. You can't really control it.
That person has to have
control of that sparkle.
Jeff was one of those kids that had like
this sparked to him. He was charismatic.
He was funny. He was smart, he
was witty, he was courageous,
but he just,
for whatever reason,
had like a little spin to them that
didn't mind getting in trouble.
It's almost like an attitude like,
hey, these guys can't hold me down.
And so, you know, when
we were in fifth grade,
it was actually in fifth grade where we
sat next to each other every day and we
would start, you know, we,
we would just hang out all the time and
laugh and eventually he started getting
in trouble and I didn't write
and I would get in some trouble,
but he would cross the line and he
crossed the line to where all of a sudden,
you know,
he would get it sent to the principal's
office and be that kind of trouble one
level above that kind of trouble I
would get in, which is like, hey,
you get yelled at, you gotta
be quiet. Hey, you know,
you go sit in the corner to those things
I got, but I didn't cross the line,
which is hey, I'm not, I'm
out of control in the class.
I'm so disruptive that you
got to get me out of class.
I'd never crossed that line.
He started crossing that
line and eventually,
you know, like, and I told
him the story, you know,
he started using drugs and
alcohol and I thought about it,
what do I want to talk about? Drugs and
alcohol and the warrior can podcast.
And then I thought to myself,
yes I do.
Because if you don't think kids hear
about drugs and alcohol right now when
they're seven years old, eight years
old, nine years old, you're wrong,
drugs are out there.
It's a different world and you might as
well tell them when they're young that
these things are problematic.
Well with Jeff, you know,
Jeff went down the path of starting to,
you know,
smoke and drink and and all that stuff,
doing drugs and I didn't, you know,
he started getting into
that kind of thing.
I started getting into like hardcore
music and being like disciplined and all
that stuff, which again, I call
it what you want, call it a trend,
call it me conforming to something
or whatever you want to call it.
But that's what I did. That's
what I got into. I related to it.
Let me put it to that way.
So eventually Jeff becomes like a burnout,
you know what I mean? He, he becomes,
um, yeah, like a burnout, you know,
you cut classes and he, you know,
just kind of went down that spiral.
And the weird thing is we were such
good friends when we were kids that we
didn't not like each other anymore.
You know,
I didn't like have a falling out with him.
We just,
we just went our separate ways.
And so when I would see him in school
where I'd see him in the hallway or I'd
see him in town, you know, we
would talk and you could see,
I could see in his eyes,
like in his eyes,
like he knew he was going in the wrong
direction and we would still laugh and we
would still have a good time.
We would joke about things and then we'd,
we'd walk away from each other and
he'd keep kept going down the path.
He was going down and I kept going
down the path I was going on.
And as time went by, you know, he just
was a complete burnout. I thought,
I don't even remember if he
graduated high school or not.
I graduated high school and I
joined the navy and you know,
I was going to go try and be a seal.
That was my big, big goal. Right.
And he was going to do
whatever he was going to do.
And the last time I saw him again,
like I remember I saw him
and it was like in my mind,
and it wasn't quite mature enough
to really recognize what I,
what I saw like at the time. But
as I look back on, it was like,
there was like this element of sadness
for him seeing that I was gone.
I was like, for lack of a
better word, like getting
away. Right. I was going to go,
I was going to go and do something right.
And he was gonna not,
and you could see that.
And at this point,
like I don't even know if he
could have gotten the military.
He'd been on quite a bit of trouble and
had used a lot of drugs and I don't even
know if he could have gotten in the
military at this point. So, and,
but when we were little kids,
mind you,
we were running around and
playing BB gun wars and you know,
setting up forts and run around
in camouflage outfits, you know,
that's what we're doing.
So it's like I was going to do that for
real and he was going to keep doing what
he was doing, which was not good
stuff. And it's when I saw him for the,
for the last time,
you know,
like we shook hands and again,
like I could see in his eyes this,
this element of sadness that
he was doing what he, his life had
gone in this direction in my life,
had gone in this other
direction and he was,
I don't even want to use the term jealous
because I don't think he was jealous.
He wasn't jealous and
all he was absolutely,
I was actually like kind of proud
you could see in his eyes like, man,
that's awesome. And he said
like, good luck. You know,
and we show hands and at bro Hugged
and then I, then I just, you know,
I left to join the navy
and went to bootcamp and,
and I remember I was in seal training
and I was probably a month or two into
seal training. And I
talked to my mom and, um,
she told me that, that
this guy, this Guy Jeff,
who had been my best friends from probably
first grade through like fifth grade.
And then, uh, like I said, it's separated,
but he killed himself and 19
years old he killed himself.
And, and so in the, in the
story that Uncle Jake tells,
I don't tell that part the talk about
suicide, but I just say that he,
he died and he died from drugs and
alcohol, which indirectly is true.
Um,
you know,
that's what killed him is that he was
doing drugs and drinking and he wasn't
making clear decisions and
went down that path of,
of depression and ended up
killing himself. And, and
I remember going, you know,
I was going through seal training.
So I was definitely
shocked and saddened by it.
And I had to do work and
it was one of those things,
but as I looked back on it,
like these are just little tiny decisions.
Like I made a decision. He
made a decision, I made a
decision. He made a decision,
I made a positive decision about
something. He made a negative decision.
I made a good decision.
He made a bad decision.
These aren't huge decisions
that I'm talking about. Yeah,
but it was these little tiny decisions
that added up over time and I think a lot
of times kids, they don't recognize that.
They don't recognize that these little,
I mean sure, if you make a
one big bad decision, you go
drinking and driving. Yup,
you're right. You can, you can kill
yourself. You can kill someone else.
You can ruin your whole
life in one bad decision.
But where did that one
bad decision came from?
It came from a bunch of bad decisions.
It came from hanging around with them,
bad people. It came with starting
to drink in the first place.
That came with even having the attitude
that I can get away with stuff.
Like there's a lot of little bad decisions
that led up to this one bad, big,
bad decision that actually ends
up putting you in a bad way.
So that's the story that I just
told on the warrior kicked podcasts.
And again, I know it's kind of a heavy
story. In fact, it's a very heavy story.
And that's another thing with
like, as I said to myself, well,
should I talk about,
should I say that he ended up
in jail or something like that.
And as I said to myself, no,
like this is the reality of life.
And if kids are not taught the
reality of life again, yeah.
I'm not trying to smack him in the
face with it. I'm not trying to,
to make them paranoid,
you know?
And that's kind of why I thought the
suicide part was a step too far. Yeah.
But you know, it's like in
Mikey and the dragons, I,
I talk about how there's dragons
that are ready to kill. And luckily,
you know,
I'm publishing,
I own the publishing company that's
making this up because a lot of my editors
probably wouldn't like to hear that a
normal children's editor doesn't want to
hear killing. Right. And as
[inaudible] and also in the book, the,
the king dies, right? The
king is dead and he's,
there's a funeral form.
And that was another thing like,
well how do you really want to
talk about that with little kids?
And as I asked my that self that
question for the first time,
I answered it in like a millisecond with
there's kids out there whose dad dies
when they're five years old whose mom
dies when they're seven years old,
whose grandma dies, who's dog
dies. Like death is part of life.
And to pretend that it doesn't exist and
hope that your kids are just gonna one
day figured out, that's not,
that's not the right thing to do.
They should understand it.
And so the,
the last part about this thing about Jeff
was,
you know, again, he had this spark, he
was funny and he was just a really good,
awesome guy.
And when I got done,
you know what I did? I
did like the typical, um,
whatever, 11 o'clock at night,
sitting at the computer thing,
when I got done writing this
thing and I just googled him,
I just googled them and just
googled his name is full name. And
it was the weirdest thing
because when I googled him,
there was nothing,
no nothing, not a ne, you
couldn't his name, no obituary,
no nothing,
just nothing.
And that kind of shook me up a little bit.
And the way it shakes me up as
it shakes me up in the fact that
that guy had more intelligence than me.
He had more talent than me.
He was more charismatic than me.
He had all these things that were
better than me and yet Google,
which I don't know if you ever Google
because I Google a lot of stuff all the
time. Cause I, I googled, you know, people
that were in the military, I Google, uh,
old authors, poets, um, people
that wrote some random, like I'll,
I'll find online, some letter from
some lance corporal in World War II.
I'll Google that person and guess what,
that person will,
there'll be an article about them,
there'll be,
there'll be his obituary about what
he did with his life. And that's,
that's what about his wife.
And then his wife died in 1968 and she
had done and so you can get so much
information about just anyone,
anyone.
And so I Google my friend
Jeff and there's nothing,
nothing.
And that's a person that Jeff had,
he gone down the right path.
He would have left a giant mark on
the world and would have done a lot of
positive things and done beautiful things
in the world and to think that it's
all gone and it's all lost.
It's lost and there's not
a damn thing about them.
So teach your kids to make the
right decisions is what I'm saying.
Yeah. So, so much for the, uh,
like I said so much for the levity of the,
of the situation or of the podcast.
Oh yeah. I mean, yeah,
it's crazy how like, you
know, obviously on it,
I didn't know Jeff,
but like how you say you were
talking earlier how you know,
if you would have made maybe even
three, three good decisions, you know,
because like these problems like drugs
and alcohol and stuff like that as an
individual problem, that's not
the maker of the breaker in there.
It's like everything put together.
You know,
there's people who were successful that
may struggle with drugs and alcohol even
for a little bit, for a long
time, ongoing like, you know,
you don't have to die if you make the
decision to do the mistake in my opinion,
but to do drugs and drink alcohol,
you know,
or have that kind of holds you back or
whatever. You don't have to die from that.
It's like everything,
you know,
and he could have been potentially like
massively successful tonal just because
of decisions.
That's the,
that's the horrible thing about it is you
just see the waste of human potential.
I guess. That's to me is the,
is a horrible thing. And I
got these great memories.
Like I got 'em right now, I can
remember doing things with him. And,
and when you're with someone like that
and you're almost like a spectator to
their life, like you're getting to
watch them, you get to go like, wow,
look at what he's doing. This is crazy. Oh
Wow. Look at that. Look how funny he is.
You get to be a spectator and you
appreciate it. I did. I appreciate it.
And right now I look back and I think
about how funny and, and you know,
I think about any random,
you know,
standup comedian or someone on a Saturday
night live or something like that.
And it's like, yeah, no, he would
have been awesome on that show.
He would've been hilarious on that show.
But never going to happen. It's not,
doesn't exist. And yeah, so,
so those little decisions that people
make and that kids make, especially,
yeah. You know what's weird too is
when you're 19 years old, think about,
think about how much you thought you
knew when you were 19 and how much you
actually know. You knew when you
were 19 it's, it's, it's a pathetic,
it's, it's, you know, so
little when you're 19 you know,
so little when you're 19
yeah man, feel like you
kind of know, well I dunno,
people are different. But
Man, even 29 for sure.
I feel like I didn't really know
well I I every five years that you look
back you realize that you didn't know
anything five years ago and maybe someone
will chime in and tell me that when
you're 72 you're, you feel pretty good
about what you know. But I don't think so.
I don't think so.
I think it's just always constantly
looking back five years and think to
yourself, and you know, I've
said before, it was like,
I think when you get to be at some point,
it's some, some decade along there,
35 40 you at least say,
I know I don't know everything.
And that is like the beginning of knowing
something. Because when you're like,
like you said, when you're 19 you know
you think you would know everything.
When you're 23 you think
you know everything.
When you're 26 you think
When you're 31 you still
think you know everything.
It's not until you actually look up.
Maybe that's 35 maybe that's 37 maybe
some people get it younger where they
realize, you know what, I don't know
everything and I need to learn more.
So there you go. Tina
learning more. Q and a.
People have some questions.
Let's see if Jocko as the answers.
I don't,
I don't necessarily have the
answers the no, but I have,
I will be able to give my assessment.
Sure.
I will say this and I just got done
telling Pete this. Sure. Yesterday,
and I probably have told you this before.
If I ever tell you I know something
100% then it's factually true,
but I do that so rarely. It's
very rare that I say, hey,
here's the, here's the answer. I
probably do that. I do that very,
very Seldomly. If you hear
me say that, go with it.
It's correct. Won't barely
hear me. You probably,
you may have never heard me
say that up until this point.
Not that I can remember. Yeah. I
very rarely will say, hey, look,
I know this all 100% I used to say once
every, maybe twice, every six months,
like when I was in the seal teams, I would
every once in a while I'd have to say,
listen man, I'm telling you this is
how you want to do this. You should.
This is how you should do
this. I'm telling you, you
do it this way. Very seldom.
Most of the time I'd say, look,
this is what I think you should do,
but it's your decision. You can
do what you want. All right. Well,
so I will give my assessment.
I'll give my best possible.
And the other thing is
these questions are,
there's not a lot of detail to them often,
or there's a ton of detail,
but even on a ton of detail isn't
like, like, let me talk. Oh,
you got a problem with your boss.
I need to meet your boss,
I need to talk to them. You interact
with them everyday. I don't meet.
So you need to kind of,
you need to kind of modulate and,
and honed the answers to
your particular scenario.
So what do you think about
this particular scenario?
Is it better to work in a mindless job
and make money or is it better to follow
your passion and possibly make less money?
I definitely think the best thing to do
is work at a job that you're passionate
about and make a lot of bunny.
That's, that's the best thing to do.
I do know that one. Uh, that's
not always possible. Any.
And here's something you've
got to be careful of.
If you ever heard people talk
about making your hobby, your job,
and generally that's like,
oh, I, if I make my hobby my
job, then I'll enjoy my job.
Right?
There's another way of looking at it.
If you make your hobby your job,
you won't like your hobby anymore.
That's another way of looking at that.
So it depends on what kind of like a
Jujitsu instructor. Yeah. Right. Hey,
I'll just open my own
school and then I'll just,
I'll just get to do what
I love all day long.
You talked to a lot of Jujitsu
instructors after six years.
They don't even like going to the academy.
They don't want to go to the academy
anymore cause it's all is. Ah, yeah.
I don't want to teach to one another
white belt, how to do an arm lock.
They're over it.
So it's not necessarily the best thing
to make what you're passionate about.
And there's some people that teach you
to do every single day and they love it
and that's awesome. And so
they've, they've won, right?
Because they're making money,
they're doing,
they're have a good livelihood
and they enjoy doing it. So yeah.
But my goal would be to do
something that I'm passionate about.
At the same time,
you've got to set yourself up so that
you're not stuck without any money. Right.
Because passion doesn't pay the rent.
I'll tell you a, an example of this,
Greg train. Sure. Years Ago
Greg trained said to me, Hey,
here's my options. I can like kind
of scrape by, teach wrestling,
teach some Jujitsu and
trained to fight or I can go,
I got accepted into this program to be
an x ray technician and he asked me,
he's like, what do you, what do you think
I should do this for a long time ago,
it's probably like 10 or 12 years
ago, maybe even longer. Anyways,
he asked me and I said, listen, how
many hours a day do you want to train?
And I said, how many hours a day can
you train? And he's like, I don't know,
maybe three or four hours a day.
Okay,
so if you want to do this three or four
hours a day and you're not going to make
any money, what are you going to do
with the other whatever, 20 hours a day?
You could actually build a career and
make real money doing the x ray thing and
then you could still easily,
because you work eight hours a day.
I was like, I was like, Greg, I work
12 hours a day. I work 14 hours a day.
I'm still here training.
You can work an eight hour day and still
train and you can train four hours a
day and you can be fine
and you'll have money.
You don't have to worry about paying
the rent, you won't have to deal.
We have to buy nice things. You'll have
medical insurance, all those things.
And he made the decision to go to extra
school and he ended up doing great in
Jujitsu and doing great in fighting.
And he ended up getting some
injuries that were like,
if he would've just been a fighter,
they would have been really
problematic because you know,
he couldn't fight for a long time.
He, so, um, that's the kind of,
that's the kind of judgment
call, right? You can make, um,
now what,
what this question is saying though is
can you do something where you make a
little less but you're passionate about?
That's,
that's pretty easy call
as far as I'm concerned.
If you just make a little bit less,
but you love doing it,
well that's kind of a no
brainer. Yeah, right, isn't it?
Now you've got to ask yourself,
where does that put you in the future?
And then you got to ask yourself,
but on the other side is could you do
this job that you don't really like for
long enough that you
could make a difference?
Like you could do this job that you
don't really like and you all of a sudden
you got a down payment for a
house and then you go buy a house.
You see what I'm saying?
Yeah. That's not a bad movie.
Eat a bad move either,
but you could also,
this is where people trap themselves.
They have the job that they didn't like.
They're making a little bit more money
and instead of investing towards getting
out of that job and setting themselves
up so where they can do something that
they are passionate about, what they do
is they expand their lifestyle. Yeah.
That's the big mistake. They expand their
lifestyle and all of a sudden, you know,
they're making $100,000 a year at this
job that they don't really like the other
job.
They were going to get $75,000
a year and that that's not bad.
Right. I would probably go for the
thing that I really liked doing.
If it's just a difference of $25,000
that's kind of a no brainer to me.
What does the person do? They say, okay,
well I'll just stay in this job so I can
make enough money to get a down payment
on a house. And then what do
they do? They buy a new car,
they go out to dinner every night.
They spend that extra 25,000 that they
could be putting into saving up for down
payment. They spend it on
stuff that they don't need.
They end up with $110,000 lifestyle
while they're making $100,000 a year and
they actually go into debt and now they're
further away from the job that they
wanted.
So
I guess the answer here is,
and I've said this before,
come up with an exit strategy with
contingencies if things go wrong and then
plan, save, prepare in the next cute.
Sounds like a good plan. Good take
on it. That's what it sounds like.
The, I found that when you
make your hobby, your career,
a lot of times like when you
have fantasies about doing
your hobby as a critic,
let's say I'm a photographer,
right? That's a big one.
That's a common one that hurt.
There'll be like,
okay cause I like taking pictures
or like, you know, I dunno,
maybe traveling or I dunno, whatever,
whatever. I like taking pictures of,
I like that kind of subject to,
oh but so a lot of things when you're
a creative person or you're into,
let's say you make baskets,
you make the awesome baskets,
but to make it your career,
a lot of the times it comes with like
50% if not 100% additional chores and
tasks,
but running that business.
Yeah, I was going to say, yeah, you
like making baskets. Oh yeah. Cool.
And what you end up doing is making
thousands of the same baskets.
They're green with the Easter bunny in it.
And that's what your job is,
to weave that basket over
over everything that you're
doing it for is now gone. And, and
guess what? You have to do it night,
you have to do half to like as a hobby.
That's kind of in my opinion pretty much
the one of the two things that make a
hobby so great is because it's fun to do
and you can do it whenever you want as
long as you have the time, as long
as you can do it whenever you want.
If you don't feel like doing,
if you don't do it,
if you don't feel like golfing tomorrow,
you don't feel like all fine,
how are you going to go? Oh no you don't.
You of course not. You don't have to,
but if you love making baskets and you
don't feel like it and you're like, Hey,
guess what?
You got to make a thousand of those.
I know you don't feel
like even making one.
You got to make a thousand now or make
sure they're done or something and you're
like,
man,
I used to love this thing now I don't
really like it cause all this pressure
which had nothing to do with my
hobby by the way. Nothing now.
It has everything to do with my hobby.
Now you've got ed and I have
people calling me saying,
hey, where's my basket? Hey,
I'm the basket maker. I say
when the basket gets made
kind of thing that's gone.
So yeah, so you don't really like it. And
so yeah, you've got the repetitiveness,
the the, the like we call that
could control lack of control,
the pressure pressure.
And then that's not to mention like
day to day chores that allow your hobby
activity to be a business
or career or whatever.
Man, it's a lot like
freaking tea, Texas. Oh Man.
Taxes doing all. Yeah man.
You know how like when you're,
you work at like a job and
the texts are just taken out,
the taxes taken out and all this stuff.
But man, you're weaving baskets, you know,
in your, in your new garage or whatever.
Man, you got to do your taxes. All this.
And I don't know man,
there's just a lot more to it.
Would you switch over from
hobby to career? That's true.
So that's my big shout out to my tax guy.
He rock so hard is the best guy ever.
I can dig it.
But yeah, so there's that and then, but
yeah, if you're prepared for that though,
if you're totally prepared for that
or if you kind of like business,
you know that part of it. Cause there's
a lot of chores in business. Yeah.
And if you liked that stuff, oh man,
that can be good. But yeah, it, oh,
and here's the thing too about when
you get a good job, I'm not a good job,
but a high paying job, but you
don't like it. This is why.
This is what I think anyway.
I don't think I've ever had
a junk job that paid a lot.
You just said junk, low paying jobs. Yes.
I had a few of those. Yes, for sure. Um,
so well, okay. I wake up, I go
to my job, drag myself to my job,
right.
Drag myself and then I can't wait to get
home and get home and get that paycheck
after a week, two weeks or whatever.
You get that huge paycheck.
And then I got to drag
myself to my job again.
Then I go home and I can let me re so
basically your day to day for that junk
job is, so John, I need something, I
need pleasure, I need some for sure.
Pleasure in my life by that cool new car.
So now,
oh sure I'll drag myself to my job but
at least I'm rolling in that new nice new
car. Or eventually you trap
yourself with that car.
That car is a trap because that becomes
the focus a lot of the times like makeup
and the, I believe so.
This is an interesting
thing I've thought about.
People like to make things,
people like to make things like it's a,
it's a,
it's a good feeling to make
something to create something.
And I think a lot of the consumer
attitude comes from the fact that look,
I don't have time to go
and build the desk. Hmm.
I wish I did have time to go build a desk
but I'll just go click on this button
and the desk will show up at my house
and it's kind of like I created something
wall. Ah, there it is. And the, and
that gives you that. But the thing is,
it's a, it's a short term.
Gratification is, yeah, the end.
That's why it keeps going because you go,
okay, I really like to make a desperate,
I'm just gonna buy this one.
Or I'd really like to do,
you know what I'd love to do is just is
just completely refurbished an old car.
Oh I can't do that, but guess what? I can,
I can just buy a new car and then
enrollment, it feels good for a minute.
But you don't get the pure,
you don't get the deep satisfaction
that you would have gotten had you
refurbished the car. Yeah. So
you get, you trap yourself.
So keep your spending in check.
This is another part of this whole deal.
Keep spending in check.
But that spending feels so good.
And then you know how like when you get
depends because there's sometimes when
you don't have a lot of money
spending hurts, you know,
it hurts when you're like,
I can't separate myself from this money.
Yeah. And you have, you have
a different mindset I think,
but I think your average person,
me included, it's like the,
the spending hurts when you spend spend
on stuff you need rather than what you'd
like want. You know what I'm
saying? So backwards. Oh yeah.
It is so backward in time, but it's a
short term thing for sure. It's like the,
the immediate like satisfaction
is like when you got to pay,
let's say you don't really have dental
insurance, right? Or let's say you do,
but you still got to pay up or whatever.
You got to spend your money on that.
Let's say it's $1,000 and you have
$1,500 in your bank account, we'll say,
so it doesn't feel good
to spend on dental,
but it would have felt good to buy a new
plasma screen TV that you could watch
the UFC. Think about it, bro.
When that plasma TV comes
in, you're like, oh my gosh,
I can't wait to hook this up.
This thing is awesome.
I'll even put it on my credit card and
pay for that thing over the next 12
months. 50% interest on
this thing. I'll do that.
No problem because of that pleasure
of getting it, but oh, dental,
you mean this too thick will go away.
This is too thick.
That's causing me of my green
will go away and then I got it.
You know? Then when it's time to pay
that bill, you're like, it's hard man.
You don't really want it. It's
weird. Chet is backwards. All right,
well like I said,
come up with a plan,
come up with an exit strategy
with contingencies and
then save money and execute
gets on check.
Next question.
How do you suggest setting sop standard
operating procedures where none
currently exist? Yeah,
good question and this is
not going to spend a ton of time on this.
Well,
the best way to develop sop says to let
them be developed organically sort of
from the people that are actually
doing that task. Whatever it is,
and you kind of,
you,
you just turn what's actually
happening into an sop.
And then if there's multiple
methods happening for something,
you kind of consolidate the methods
into the best way and then test them and
then you'll have your sop there.
One thing that you shouldn't do with an
sop is come up with a standard operating
procedure inside of a vacuum and then
push it down on the folks below you in the
chain of command because they're going
to be, they're going to reject it. Um,
they are going to,
they are going to know a better way of
doing it cause you made it up in a vacuum.
So,
so don't do that.
Now there are some times where let's say
you're going to do something brand new
that's never been done before and
you have to kind of create an sop.
Then if you have to do that, you you
need to kind of explain to the team,
hey listen guys, we've never
done this type of mission before.
We've never done this
type of project before.
Here's my best guess at what a standard
operating procedure is going to look
like. We're going to try and execute
this, but believe me, it's not perfect.
I'm open to feedback and I
realized that it's going to change,
but I want to at least have a
line for us to deviate from.
And actually this is an extreme ownership.
I talked about how we
started organizing the SSC,
the sensitive slight sense
of sight exploitation.
It's how we search to buildings and
it's in the book, but when you first,
when we first started searching builders,
would everyone just go in and ransack
everything and just throw everything
around and it was totally ridiculous and
ineffective and eventually, you know,
I said,
okay,
we need a standard operating procedure in
my assistant platoon commander. I said,
hey, come up with a standard operating
procedure of how we're going to do this.
He did that. And when he did of course,
and it's in the book, people are like, oh,
this is going to take forever. And it was
like, okay listen, we're going to try it.
If there's some adjustments we've
got to make, we'll make them,
but let's at least give it a try
it. And that's what we did. Um,
and one of the best things you can do if
you have to come up with an sop is not
only let it come organically
from the task itself,
but let the people that are actually
doing the task come up with the standard
operating procedures.
So if you had,
if you had some project that
you did over and over again,
I wouldn't come and say,
Hey, here's what I want,
how I want you to do this project
from now on Echo. I'd say, Hey, echo,
since you're doing this all the time,
can you capture what it is you do? And,
and we can take those best practices,
turned them into a standard operating
procedure and get him the whole through
the whole organization. And
you'd say, oh, that's cool.
You had kind of feel some ownership of
that and then you would put together a
good plan.
So that's pretty straight forward with
the standard operating procedures,
the the main thing is let them
develop, led the team, develop them,
keep an open mind,
don't force him down people's throat.
Next question.
I'm a 17 year old.
I'm a blue belt in Jujitsu,
which I received a few days after my
16th birthday and I have ambitions of
pursuing Jujitsu professionally and
competing to the highest level possible.
Of course this requires discipline
and commitment.
So during the school term I trained you
to two Monday through Saturday and I
weight train on Friday and Sunday.
And when I have time off school,
I trained Jujitsu three times a day.
However,
due to my commitment to this
and my refusal to prioritize
the other things over
this,
I feel I'm missing out on the social
opportunities of this part of my life.
I Miss Parties and social events in
order to stranger Jitsu and weight train
because I know that I should
have the discipline to do so.
However I feel lonely and
isolated because of it.
Is this just weakness or should I make
the occasional exception for a social
event? Once again, love the work you
do. You have an echo. Do it's an hour.
It's helped me immensely.
Thanks from the UK.
All right. The UK. Um, uh, first of
all, I'd just, okay. The hardcore,
here's the couple of hardcore answers.
Hardcore answer number.
What's your schedule like? Are
you wasting any time? Have you,
have you maxed them,
maximize the hours you can get out of a
day or are you spending time doing other
things that you shouldn't be doing?
That being said,
it sounds like you're
getting after it pretty hard,
which means you're probably pretty
efficient. And if you're, if you're
not wasting a bunch of time and you're
not doing a bunch of things that are non
productive and you're
feeling lonely and isolated,
then guess what? You're
going too far. You don't,
you should not be feeling
lonely and isolated. That's
not good. You need to relax.
Especially because if you're training
that much, you're likely overtraining.
So broadly speaking, now, broadly
speaking, training should be enjoyable.
Okay? This doesn't mean that
you're gonna love it every day.
And I talked about that all the time.
It doesn't mean every day you
wake up and you're all, you know,
smile from one year to the other year
cause you're so happy you've got to go do,
you know, squats and dead lifts and like,
no, that doesn't happen. But broadly,
the way it makes you feel,
the way Jujitsu makes you feel it should
make the other times when you go on to
g two Matt and you get spanked and you
get ground out and you get tapped out and
you feel like junk. Yes, that going
to happen. But again, broadly,
how does Jesus who make you feel?
It makes you feel good.
You should enjoy it to some extent,
right?
And you should not be getting burnt out.
And I think that's the most important
thing is that you shouldn't be getting
burnt out on Jujitsu, on working out. And,
and this is, this is important,
especially for your 17 years old,
there is more to life than
Jujitsu and physical fitness,
right? There's more to, there's more to,
there's more to doing.
Well in life than just
Jujitsu and physical fitness.
So a couple things.
If you can't,
if you can't communicate
with people effectively,
that's a real problem in any environment.
Right?
And if you're isolating yourself
from other people and you're not,
you're not learning how to interact
with other human beings in a social
environment, that's not good. And it's
not only, it's not only that, it's,
it's not only that,
it's just not good for you because yes,
you as a person that you need to be
well rounded. You need to be, yes,
you need to be strong. You need to be
capable from a fighting perspective,
but you also need to be smart.
You need to be articulate.
You need to be quick witted
yeah.
And those things are mandatory
skills in life. I mean,
if you're a black belt in Jujitsu and
you're a white belt in the communicating
with other human beings, that's not
going to be a good situation for you.
And the other thing is,
the better you are,
the more well rounded you are in all these
other aspects of life of those things
will actually make you better. At jujitsu
cause you'll be able to read people,
you'll be able to deal with confrontation,
you'll be able to understand other
people's motivations and all those things
come from interacting
with other human beings.
So I get it,
I get the massive commitment
and that is what it takes.
Like if you want to compete at the
highest level, I'm telling you, yes,
you have to live, breathe and
eat Jujitsu. You have to live,
breathe and eat conditioning.
And that being said,
if that's all you live,
breathe and eat,
yeah,
that's gonna make you less apt to be
a champion then if you make yourself a
little bit more well rounded
in some of these other aspects.
So dude,
keep training hard.
17 year old blue belt from UK.
Keep training hard,
go out occasionally hang out with
some people, have a good time.
And that by no means means get
hammered every time you do it at all.
Not at all. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That
social aspect, man, that's like, that's,
it seems like a lot of times,
especially when you're training,
are you doing something that's kind
of directly or can be viewed as like
directly opposite of a social thing?
Can you know when you think socially
you're thinking all you guys are just
slacking, hang it out according to the
Bar, cruising at the beach, whatever.
Well, while we're over here training
kind of thing. Right? Just like,
just like people say, Oh, you're sleeping
on the couch. You know, what are you lazy?
Sleeping on the couch warm. I Dunno.
Maybe they need rest, you know?
Or there there's, there,
there is use in sleep.
Seems like that was a,
that was a little,
maybe kind of a glimpse into
the Echo Charles world right
there. Maybe. Maybe not.
It doesn't let you sleep on the couch.
Maybe I need rest.
Maybe I'm recovering from Norco state.
I'm saying.
I'm saying there's two parts of it.
You know that there's that and
so in people give it a bad rap.
I think especially like you,
you know how like, you know,
you hear these motivational gurus
grind all sleep when I'm dead,
you know, that kind of thing,
right? Yeah, I say that. So
I you said it, not me, but
hey, all right, so the,
and I'm not saying that you know, that's
dumb or nothing like that. I'm saying,
I'm saying that it,
it produces a certain message that can
be interpreted in a way that might not be
the most beneficial. Well,
I'm sure I think this, this,
I'm glad that he asked this question
because he's taken the attitude of like,
okay, I'm going to sleep when
I'm dead and I'm going to,
I'm going to hang out with other human
beings after I'm a world champion. Right.
And again, do you need to be possessed
to be a world champion? Yes, you do.
But all I'm saying is part of the things
that will make you be a better well
rounded person, the more well rounded you
are, the better you're going to perform.
Yeah. You know, you're going to
learn how to deal with anxiety.
You're going to learn
how to deal with people.
You're going to learn how to
look at someone else's situation,
look in their eyes and be like,
okay, this guy's stressed out,
or this guy's panicking,
or this guy, you know,
you learn those things from
interacting with other people.
That's gonna make you a better competitor.
You're going to learn more about yourself.
That's going to make you a
better competitor. Yeah, and
you're going to be, if you,
if you relax now, what you don't want to
do is go so far in the other direction.
We show up to a competition and you don't
feel like you've prepared as much as
you could, but that, what does that
do? You go too far the other direction.
Now you overtrained. Yeah, so
you got to find a little bit of,
but sounds like you're a
little bit off balance,
especially because you're feeling like
the words that kind of keyed me off the
most in this was, what was it? Lonely
and isolated. That's what kind of key,
if you said everything else here and
then you are like, am I overtraining?
I would have said, no man, you're
getting after it a good job,
but then when you say, look,
I feel lonely and isolated.
You don't want to feel
lonely and isolated like,
and that's another thing when I changed
Jitsu, that's kind of where I hang out.
Like I don't interact with people.
Normally it's a social thing.
We might not even talk,
we might not even say one word other than
do you want a roll? And then we train.
That's sort of my social activity of,
of hanging around with other people and
I don't feel I leave the gym and I feel
like I hung out with a lot of people.
I didn't say anything to them,
but if you feel lonely and isolated,
that's not good. That's getting to you.
That means your mind is starting
to be worn down from this.
Don't let it get worn down.
It's going to refuel you to go out.
It's going to watch this. Watch this.
If you're feeling lonely and isolated,
your workout that day is like a nine.
If you feel like like, Hey, I'm having
a good life. I'm filled with energy.
I like hanging out.
I just had a good time with this girl
last night and now I'm going to train.
It's like, oh, okay, guess what?
That's workouts at 9.7 you get a better
training cause you had a good time. Yeah.
So yeah,
I don't like to,
I don't like the fact that he says he's
lonely and isolated. That's not good.
And again, this is just a dichotomy
because then you'll get someone that says,
okay well chocolates would go out
and you don't have party, you know,
party and party with the ladies
and then and then yeah, it'll
help my workout. And then while, you know,
maybe if I only work out three times a
week and I spend most of my time partying,
I'll be just,
I'll get workouts level 11 no you won't.
So yeah,
man,
make some exceptions to your discipline
and go enjoy the company of some other
people. Grow a little bit as a person.
Become a better human, compete better,
train harder. That's it. Agree.
This is a concept that I think is if you
can kind of incorporate or understand
this concept in, you know, when
you're working hard at something.
So when I was young, when I first
started lifting weights first started,
I don't know 15 or what, however
we'll do. Um, so you know,
you know how when you lift weights and
you get that little pump right to me,
to me I thought that that's literally
my muscles growing. You know,
like I didn't know how it all worked.
I was like Dang my mom,
I can see the growth already.
So all they gotta do is lift every
single day and watch. I'll quit.
Cause most people,
they won't work as hard as me because
I'll just w w because I liked doing it.
I like the pump, whatever.
Um, so I would do,
we remember the guy,
my friend I mentioned Eric Masters
pilot in the air force. Yes.
So he, he had the one, he always had
the soda above the microwave. Anyway,
so I lift with him. Him and his dad would
invite me and my brother over, we'll,
we'll lift and he started off with
bench and you know this stuff.
So we go lift and I'm like, damn,
I feel a pump. So now when I,
when we trend kind of went into,
I want to say like varsity football,
I don't know. Anyway, we were,
we started lifting in the
weight room at the high school.
So I would do the same thing every single
day, every single day, every single day.
And my friend was like, this
other guy I know. He goes,
hey you are you benching every
single day? And I was like, yeah.
And he was like, Bro, your muscles
aren't going to grow. I was like,
what are you talking about? Of course
they do. They grow every single day.
Like I feel it even he's like, Bro,
you don't know how it works. He's like,
you don't,
when you lift they don't grow.
They actually get torn and they get like
almost like a little micro injury that
that's how it works.
And then when you rest and when you
sleep and when you eat and they grow.
And I was like, whoa. And he did. It still
didn't make sense. So I was like, okay,
I guess you know, he's like, you ever
heard, you know when the soreness,
you know when you get the soreness or
whatever. I was like, yeah. He was like,
that's like it,
like hurt,
like kind of injured or whatever and then
it has to heal up and when it heals up
it heals up bigger. And I'm
like, oh, okay. It's like so
you can't bend to everyday.
Otherwise it'll just like,
it'll just won't grow it
always be damaged. I was like,
oh, makes sense. So that
rest in between workouts,
it's kind of important given
Mike Oh Gross. So muscles,
and you'll see what I'm saying where this
kind of thing where it's like all go,
all go, no arrest. Right. You
need that rest to grow literally.
And that goes for anything.
Truth,
and this is kind of the next question is
very closely related to this and that's
why I put it kind of like
right next to it. And
that is Jocko, I should have
asked it in muster zeros or six.
Is there a dichotomy,
dichotomy in the unmitigated,
unmitigated daily discipline in
all thing? Yeah, and like I said,
this is why I put this question here
because it's related to the question they
answer that I just gave, which is
yes, you can, you can overdo it.
And there is a dichotomy.
You can put so much focus on working.
Um,
you can put so much working,
so much focused on working that you
lose track of your family and everything
goes down until with your family.
Or you can do the opposite.
Put so much focus on your family that
you lose track of that you don't do what
you're supposed to do at work. Um,
so you need to back off a little. Uh,
and you get people that waste
time on things that don't matter.
This goes back to remember the podcast
we did where I was talking about how like
a black belt when a white belts grabbing,
grabbing a black belt sleeve
and it just doesn't matter.
There's people that think
that it's important that I
do this thing for a certain
way, and the reality is it's useless.
It doesn't matter. You're being OCD,
right? You're being OCD. So, or
you maybe not being full as you,
but you're being borderline.
You got to think about what's
important and what's not important.
And if you're discipline,
if you generally or oftentimes people
that are hyper disciplined about little
things,
a lot of times they're missing their
discipline in other areas of their life.
And one of them, and, and we've
talked about this before too,
which is somebody that just because
someone has hyper disciplined in their
physical fitness doesn't mean that
they're disciplined in their rest of their
life in many other ways,
whether it's financial, whether
it's their relationships,
whatever, like everything that
they can be screwing every,
they're super disciplined in weighing
their food and doing macro calorie
counting and all that stuff,
right?
And yet they haven't paid their phone
bill or whatever and they've got financial
issues or they've got
health other health issues.
And so you need to,
you need to back off enough on the little
things that don't matter that so that
the things that matter you can
actually take care of. Now,
the weird dichotomy in this is again,
it's always comes up,
the Russian soldiers in the Chechen war,
not shaving.
Is it really important that they shave?
Not really,
but what's really important is that they
have discipline overall and when they
stopped shaving faced, they let go of
their discipline and that was the problem.
Now, so there, there is
about, that's what I'm saying,
there's a balance and it gets a little,
let me,
let me make that a little more clearly.
If we were in a war and what
I was focused on was equity,
better shave tomorrow,
that was my big focus and
echo your uniform better be
squared away tomorrow like
that. That is not what the most important,
most important thing is like echo.
Do you understand where the
fallback positions are? Echo,
do you understand what your
field of fire is? Echo,
do you know what you're supposed to
do when we start getting overrun?
Those are what's important.
And,
but if I focus on this little
thing that doesn't really matter,
that can,
that can be a problem.
So I need to make sure that I'm focused
on the correct things and in life. Yes,
you can.
Unmitigated daily discipline if you try
to apply it to absolutely everything in
your life,
just like prioritize and execute.
If you try and solve all your
problems at the same time,
you won't be able to solve any.
If you try and implement
perfect discipline in every
single thing that you do,
you won't be able to apply discipline
to the things that are most important.
My garage gym floor is dirty.
Okay. I sweep it. Sure, of course.
I sweep it every third day.
I just sweep it out.
But I don't get in there with a bucket
and a mop and try and clean the chalk off
so it's perfect black. Why?
Cause it doesn't matter.
Yeah. So some things in life are
like your gym floor. It just,
it doesn't matter if there's chalk on it.
I'm going to put more chalk on it later.
The chalk doesn't make me slip.
It doesn't make me sick. It doesn't. It
doesn't, but I don't care how it looks.
So don't worry about the chalk
on the gym floor. In fact,
there's gyms in the world where you're
not allowed to have chalk cause they
don't want chalk on the gym floor.
Those places shouldn't exist in the world.
They should be. They should be illegal.
There should be chalk everywhere.
The gym available. Yeah, you're right. So
don't focus on things that don't matter.
There you go. Yeah man. It's,
see it seems like the whole discipline
equals freedom thing and whether you
agree with it or not actually you
know I think you will agree with this.
It's a dance, you know it's the
dance with discipline and freedom.
Do you mean about a balance
of a dichotomy? Yes it is.
In fact I wrote a book about it.
Thank you.
I appreciate you pointing that out to
me and it's going to be asked to take
ownership too. It just depends
on who you are. Like you,
you're the discipline is going to be
taking the lead big time, you know.
And when you exercise your
freedom with, I dunno, I dunno.
Diet wise is like what mint chocolate
chip ice cream or something like this.
When you exercise that freedom,
it's not going to be very often,
but when you do boom,
it's going to have benefits.
And that's when you see somebody that's,
let's just talk about this.
Well when you see somebody that's
out of shape, you could say,
you can say one of two things. You
could say not enough discipline, right?
Or You could say too much freedom.
We know it's one of those two things.
If you see someone that's having
financial issues, it's one or two things,
not enough discipline or too much freedom.
They're getting out that credit card
when they shouldn't be. Right. So yeah,
it goes without saying that it's a
balance. It's dichotomy. That's correct.
So even, and also on top of that,
the discipline in all things,
cause that's the question,
right? You could put,
maybe you could write a book called
the dance, the dance of leadership.
I'll just copy the leading.
We'll be all good. But the, in all
things like discipline in diet,
discipline in, um, uh, you know,
workouts and not slacking and whatever.
And that looks way different
than discipline in like
relationships for example.
Like if you're like a diff like to to,
you know,
the discipline not to lose your
temper or the discipline to,
to respond to a maybe not
disciplined person or something.
Let's say someone you love who's,
who's maybe emotionally different than
you or whatever that looks and feels way
different. You know, if, if you really
think about it, so if you're like, Hey,
I'm not gonna,
I dunno,
I'm not going to go to the park with
my wife because I'm working out.
That's my discipline.
I'm no slack, you know,
kind of base or you're lacking the
discipline to organize around your
relationship with your
relationship or whatever.
You're lacking the discipline to make
sure that your wife understands that
you're going to train. Yes, cause I don't
want to train. But as far as we're like,
and now that's back on the training again.
But like with like your relationships,
unless your relationships are important
to you, which is, I mean I would,
I would argue most times there's
some relationships in your life that,
that are going to be important.
I would argue that there should be,
I think so too.
Yes.
So maintaining discipline in those
relationships looks different.
So it might not be as obvious.
So when someone says Ma Unlimited,
when you say unmeeted gated
discipline and all things,
I don't think automatically right off
the top of my head. Like, Oh, you know,
my relationship with my wife, you know,
or even the relationship with your kids.
Like when I think unmitigated
daily discipline in all
things, including my kids.
So I'm gonna,
I'm gonna make sure they're disciplined
all but the discipline of you,
of yourself dealing with the kids,
that's a whole different thing.
See what I'm saying? True. So you've
got to kind of keep those in my, Oh,
I've found, yeah, I find that
when I want to keep that in mind,
it'll help and then, yeah, and
do the dance. With freedom,
you designate how much freedom you are
going to exercise and then you do the
dense, assume sane, you balance
the dichotomies. What she'd do bro,
you dance. It's like, and here's the,
here's the wrong thing.
What I made a mistake of w at one point
long time ago I looked at you and I was
like, shoot, I need to do
that. I need to wake up,
I need to like do all this stuff with
it. But if, if I were to do that,
I jumped myself up
so I can't like you can't use like the
next person as the standards as far as
the balance goes. Like you have to
designate your own balance. Yeah.
Cause you have to modulate
for your life. Yeah. Whatever.
Brown people don't just automatically
know that. I know I didn't check,
figured it out. I didn't see you getting
up at four 30 if at any point though.
Yeah, I tried to check. Anyway.
Next question.
Is there one form or type of Jujitsu
that is better than other forms?
Not Japanese versus small circle Jujitsu,
but pressure versus movement.
Bottom versus top.
Different types of quote unquote
games. Got It. Yeah. So there's,
if you don't know this, there's
different types of Jujitsu in the world.
There's things like he mentioned here,
there's Japanese Jujitsu
and there's something called
small circles she's doing.
Then there's just a million different
kinds of random sort of names that people
will put on Jujitsu.
Right.
The one that we do is generally
referred to as Brazilian Jujitsu.
I just generally for trued as Jitsu
because that's what I'm talking about. Uh,
so there are different types of
all the different types of Jujitsu.
The one that you should be doing is
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu. The other types
are not what you want to be doing.
Jenn Rubin generally and the,
yeah, so that's just the,
that's just the reality of it. So now,
but then he's asking a different question,
which is deep inside of inside
of even Brazilian Jiu Jitsu,
there's different types of styles that
people will have and these are people end
up calling them games like what
kind of game does this person have?
What kind of game does that person have?
And different people have different
games and it depends on their body.
The different body types have different
styles, different games, different,
even different, like cardio levels can
have different games, different thoughts,
different flexibility levels,
different games, different styles,
even different personalities.
If you have different personalities,
you'll end up with a different style.
So the question is,
are there some games or some styles that
are better than other games or other
styles inside of Jujitsu?
And my answer to that I think is no,
there's not games that are
better than other games.
Not Styles of Jujitsu that are
better than other styles of Jujitsu.
It's just different.
People gravitate towards different
ones and they use them successfully and
that's why they continue to use them.
I would say this though,
if you can then develop
more than one game,
right?
More than one game.
Like if all you know how
to do is pressure pass,
that's the only kind of pass you know
and you come up against someone that's
really good at good at
defending the pressure pass,
you won't be able to pass the guard.
If you're,
if you have a really good top game but
you go against a wrestler that's a better
restaurant you and put you on your back,
then that's going to be a problem.
So d you're going to vote. And the other
thing people ask is how do I develop?
My style, the answers you just train
and your style is going to call you.
You don't know. Occasionally
someone might tell you like, hey,
you're long and Lanky, you
should use Triangley should
set up good triangle games
are good Darce chokes or
someone says, Hey, you're,
you got good base, you should,
you know, abuse, a lot of pressure.
So there can be someone
giving you some indication,
but you're going to self
select as you train what works.
And as you can continue
to do what works for you,
you'll get better and better at it. Yeah,
that's funny you said it makes sense,
like just train and it'll sort of
sort itself out. You know, your game,
your style in the, the reason,
um, this might seem kind of,
but the reason why I like these tall,
lanky guys,
they'll do like triangles and stuff
because when they first start training
though,
the triangle is going to come weight
easier than a guy who's not as Lanky,
you know, early on. So they'd be
like, oh shoot, that's successful.
So it's Kinda like check that.
That's good. So there again, boom,
that becomes part of
their game super early.
So that kind of is a dominant part of
their whole game. And then the, you know,
the more,
the more they train,
the more things are going to start falling
into place in their game. You know?
And so if you have a lengthy prayers,
all those lanky moves,
they're gonna Register
way quicker than you know,
a shorter guy or stock your guy that's,
yeah.
It's funny how you put that just train,
they'll sort of just,
they reveal themselves.
Oh yeah, they totally do
this. This question also
ties into the next question.
So I kind of coupled it up with the next
question as well. Did you, do you feel,
well, you know your answer to that.
Is there a better game or whatever?
I feel like you don't like when you watch
ADCC or something like this and then
you'd have a guy like
[inaudible] who's six,
four and then you have Marcella Garcia
guys who are arguably like just as good,
the two best guys ever to do it. And
they're just completely opposite. Yeah,
man. It's Kinda like when I
watch those kind of like, um,
like you ever heard of the game mortal
Kombat? I have heard of it. Yeah.
So it's like this is this
real violent game as 2000,
because it's like they have weapons
and stuff that they can sort of bus out
random places, games,
Scorpion, his weapon,
it's a sphere with a rope or chain or
whatever and he pulls you and he does his
thing. Then the guy who can freeze
people, you know, and the guy who can, um,
I don't know, throw his hat and
just cut people. I don't, you know,
so people have all these different
weapons, but then you would think, hey,
if a guy can freeze, a person
wouldn't, he'd be the best guy.
You just free if people, so
you've got to do, you know,
but it doesn't work itself out.
It's whoever is good at using
the little ice ray or whatever,
whatever it's called, who's better at
using that spear with the, with the rope.
Okay. We'll go with it, man.
But that's, that's the way
it works is you just did to,
I'm just saying. Well anyways,
that question relates to
the next question. Oh, okay.
Yes. Next question. Sure.
Yes. Hi Jack. Mortal Kombat
and street fighter two yes.
Actually there street fighter,
which really kind of went unnoticed
I think by the general public.
Then there's street fighter two. That's
when it sort of became like this big,
that was like the main combat game I
think with fighting street fighter two.
What years was that? I Dunno. I was in
high school who also nineties it was good.
I was doing Jujitsu worries. Yeah, man.
Well you missed out a little bit because
canola is a lot of salt on anything
street fighter two with,
there was this guy named Guile guile.
Bro. I'm telling you. I'm
telling you, revisit that.
Or in your case visit that Guile, he threw
this thing called a sonic. It's, it's,
it's a lot and just look at it.
Anyway, next question Jocko.
There's an army cliche that I'm sure
you've heard of or you've heard.
That goes,
everyone's leadership style is different.
I've heard it used many times as a
coverup for failed mission or with someone
who just isn't getting it done.
What's your opinion on this for
all the advice that you give?
There seems to be a continuous method to
your madness and some basic principles
for being a good leader.
Does everyone have a different leadership
style or is there an optimal optimal
method with personality tweaks?
That's just amazing how well this
Jujitsu comparison to this is, this is,
this is just an incredible translation.
And if you know the way broad
broadly you seen in all things,
because what this question is,
is exactly the same as the question above.
And the fact of the matter is,
if you know Jiu Jitsu Brazilian Jujitsu,
yeah.
You know the fundamental principles of it,
you can do these tweaks.
If you don't know the
fundamental principles of it,
you're just going to get destroyed now.
Okay.
If you're a catch wrestler that those
have the same sort of fundamental things
going on. You know what I mean? If
you know Samba, so if you know judo,
so I'm saying if you understand,
I don't know what to call them.
But if you understand like the fundamental
principles of submission grappling of
any kind,
if you know what those are,
then you can make some tweaks to them.
You can make some adjustments to them to
bait based on your style and your body
type and your personality and your
strengths and weaknesses. Yes,
it is the same thing with leadership.
So people are going to
have different styles.
They're going to have
different styles of leadership.
Some people are super
caring, charismatic, right?
And that person could take
advantage of their, their charisma.
Some people like connect with other
people really easily. Some people don't.
You're going to have just different little
nuances to your personality and your
brain that are going to,
that you're going to make little
adaptations and your leadership style.
That's okay.
Where it gets not okay is if you
leave the fundamental principles,
that's where you have a problem with
it. Because there was a, there's uh,
an example that I thought of
when I read this question.
There was a guy that was coming through
my training when I was running the, uh,
the advanced training for the seals and
he was making an actually leafs told
story. You remember left. He's told the
story. I think it's in the book too.
I don't remember. But it's, it's podcast
book. We've talked about it in a bunch.
We talk about it when we
took go talk to clients,
life tells this story about how he was
trying to give commands over the radio
and no one's doing anything because it's
ineffective to give commands in a radio
in a when there's a lot of machine
gun fire and all this stuff going on.
So I said,
hey leaf use verbal commands.
And He kinda like looked at me like I
was crazy and I said to him and just give
it a try. He did it. It worked.
A couple of years later I'm running
training and there's a guy that's given a
bunch of commands on the radio
and I go to him, I go, hey man,
use verbal commands. And he's like, he's
like, what do you mean? And I'm like,
yell at everyone. So they know
what it is you want them to do.
They can't hear you on the radio. There's
a lot of stuff going on. And he goes,
I don't lead that way.
That's what he said to me.
And you know,
they just got destroyed because, you know,
in his, I don't know if he thought like,
hey look, I'm not going to yet. I
wasn't telling him to yell at US people,
I was telling them like yelled the
verbal commands and he wouldn't do it.
And they just got
annihilated all the time.
And he ended up not doing well as a
leader because he was breaking the
fundamental principles of combat
leadership, like simple, clear,
concise commands that everyone understands
it. If they don't understand it,
whose fault it's yours.
And if you're talking on the
radio giving these complex orders,
people aren't gonna understand what
to do. But if you give them the, the,
the standard operating procedure,
maneuver, command peel, right,
that's going to get passed
and everyone's gonna do it.
So he strayed away from the
fundamental principles. It's like,
it's like saying, well you
know with me, if I give you,
if I use a pressure point on your
neck, then I'll win. It's like, no,
actually that's not going to be effective.
You the pressure point thing
is a fantasy. Oh No, it's real.
Oh okay. It is real. You
know what? And there's a,
there's certain parts of your body that
hurt a little bit more when you press
into them.
I understand that that doesn't change you
from getting choked doesn't change you
from getting double leg takedown.
You'd try and hit some of the pressure
point while they're doing a double leg
take down on you. You're not gonna
make it. No, it's not going to happen.
So, um, you, you, you have,
and I've told this story too about the
guy that wasn't very loud and I told him
like, Hey, you got to get louder.
And eventually he got the guys that were
allowed in his platoon to start giving
the verbal commands cause he
wasn't loud enough to do it.
And that was an effective way.
Still using the same principle,
just using a little bit of a different
technique. That's fine. So yes,
different leaders are
going to lead differently,
but the principles are going to remain
the same that the principles of ownership
cover moves,
simple,
prioritize and execute decentralized
command and balancing the dichotomies.
And then there's plenty of them in
leadership. The good leaders out there,
they will follow those principles and
they'll make little tweaks to them based
on their personality.
And that's fine.
But a tweak doesn't require an excuse
and also effective or ineffective.
Like if you make a change,
if you do something a certain
way and it's not effective,
then whatever you change, this
isn't working, it's not working.
So use the fundamental principles, make
little APP to adaptations. It's okay,
but if a leader is ineffective
and they're failing, guess what?
Their little adaptations. So like,
Hey, I could make up a new move,
right for Jujitsu and I,
and I call it the, the,
the Wizbang sure. And I say,
Hey, I made up the school move.
It's called the Wizbang
and let me show it to you.
And so I show it to and you're like,
well, I don't know if that'll work or not.
And I like, no, it'll definitely work.
The cool thing about Jujitsu is when I try
it, we find out if it works. Right now,
something doesn't work immediately,
right?
But let's say I keep drilling it on you
and Julian on you and I can never get
you in the Wiz Bank.
Okay?
And then I go on a tournament and I
tried the Wizbang and I get smashed and
defeated, and then I, I go
through the constellation bracket,
I try the Whiz Bang and it
gets smashed and defeated.
Then I go to the next tournament.
I try the wizbang going to get smashed in,
defeated.
Then I get in the constellation bracket.
I try the Wizbang and
get smashed in defeated,
and I do this for six months and the
whizzbang never works effective or
ineffective currently in effect,
it's ineffective, it's ineffective.
If you're in a leadership position or
someone's in a leadership position and
they're failing and they're failing to
execute the mission over and over and
over again,
they're little tweak that,
a little leadership thing that
they think is good to go. It's not,
it's not good to go. And it
probably, in fact, I'll tell you,
it violates one of the fundamental
principles of combat leadership.
And if you can identify which one
of those things it's violating,
you can get them to
clean it up and fix it.
So there you go. Whizz Bang. Don't
try it. Don't try the Whiz Bang.
I don't know though. I
mean these, the moves,
you know how like guys will like
out moves, man. I Dunno. It's,
it's this endless thing.
New moves come out. Yeah.
And you won't hit a move 100% of the
time and you definitely won't hit it when
you first started doing it.
It's going to be hard.
How many arm locks do you think you put
on someone before you made someone tap?
In the beginning you probably did 50
arm locks before you got someone to tap.
Yeah, probably more. Yeah.
Yeah. Maybe even more so.
That doesn't mean what the after
the first 49 outs and effective,
I'm not going to do it.
The big differences,
the big differences on arm
lock is a proven known entity.
Cover and move is a proven known entity.
Simple is a proven known entity.
Prioritize and execute
is a proven known entity.
Extreme ownership is a proven, known
and decentralized command is a proven.
It's like an all markets I could choke.
That's why when some people say to me, Oh,
well my boss doesn't
like extreme ownership,
you know, I, I know what's happening.
Like it's, they're the bosses.
Ego is offended because
there's some other,
some somebody telling them a
different way to lead. No. It's like,
what do you believe in? I don't believe
in extreme ownership. Oh, I blame him.
I believe in placing the blame on
other people. That's how I lead.
That's complete. Completely ridiculous.
Everybody knows that's ridiculous.
It's completely ridiculous. Cover move.
I don't believe in cover move. Oh,
so you just like your other team members
to go and take care of themselves and
you take care of yourself. How does that
work? It doesn't work. Keep the, Oh,
I don't like to keep things simple. No,
I like to make things so complicated.
Complicated that people don't
understand what I'm talking about.
Does that make any sense whatsoever?
No, it doesn't prioritize and execute.
No, don't do that. What I,
what I'm going to do is spread myself
so thin that I don't have the assets or
resources to actually accomplish anything.
That's what I'm going to do.
Cause that makes sense.
Cause I don't believe in extreme
ownership or those are fundamental laws of
combat leadership. That's where
you're at decentralized command. Oh,
I don't believe in that.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make every single decision myself from
the headquarters position.
When you guys want to make a decision out
there on the battlefield are out there
and the on the manufacturing floor,
I want you to run every single definitive
decision up through me cause that's
going to be effective.
So if you violate one of these principles,
you're, you're going to have problems as
a leader. If you tweak these principles,
that's fine. If you look at decentralized
command and you're like, you know what?
I know that the normal kind of
span of control is five people.
I can handle more than that. I can
handle nine and you step it up. That's,
that's tweak. That's okay.
Right? That's fine. If you pray,
when you prioritize and execute, hey,
the way I prioritize and execute,
and this is the truth,
the way I prioritize and execute isn't,
I look at my number one problem
and I only focused on that one.
I assign somebody to my number
one problem and I say, hey bill,
go handle that room over there. It's a
problem. And then I look at Mike and say,
Hey Mike,
get the rest of this hallway cleared.
So I'm actually handling two things,
but I give bill the priority.
So that's a tweak. I'm
using assets. That's fine.
So sometimes yes,
you got to make these little adjustments.
Everyone's got a different
leadership style,
but you don't violate the
principles of leadership.
Just like you don't violate the
principles of submission grappling,
I'll call it.
Yeah.
Next question.
I'm a huge fan of the podcast
and I'd like your advice.
When I was younger,
I joined the National Guard in an attempt
to do something with my life and get
out of depression.
I lost my discipline and goals after
basic training and continued in depression
and disorganization.
I had the opportunity to go
to fight to flight school,
but instead tested positive on a drug
test and I was given a general discharge.
I of course, take full
responsibility, feel like an
idiot. How would you recommend
moving past this failure?
What would you have done if your
seal career ended with a mistake?
Wolf,
my seal career had ended with a mistake.
I would have figured out what
my next mission was going to be.
That's that's what I would've done.
I mean, I would have said, okay,
I liked that job.
I failed at it.
What can I learn from that and what can
I do next differently to make sure I
don't make that mistake again?
I'm going to learn from the past,
but I'm not going to dwell on it.
There's no point in dwelling on it.
The only point in dwelling on
it just to learn from it. So,
so that's what I would do here.
And then I would take what I learned
from my experiences of where I failed.
And I would also take the positive things
that I learned because you even that
even that failure is a positive.
Even that failure as a
positive because you realize,
you realize the value of the opportunity
that you had and you blew it and you're
like, okay, I'm never gonna let
that happen again. A lesson learned,
I'm actually stoked I get to learn that
lesson because it's going to be more
opportunities that come up in life and
you've got to make sure that you don't
disregard those opportunities
when they come up.
And so I would have taken those
lessons learned, take that,
take that failure and turn it into
something positive and made good things
happen when I figured
out what my new mission,
a new career was going to be
pretty straight forward. You can,
you can do so much good.
And you know,
that's going back to the story that I
told about Jeff in the beginning of this
podcast.
One of the wording,
some of the wording that I
struggled with in the kid story,
and again it's on,
it's the word kid podcast.
One of the things that I struggled with
in telling the story was I ended up
saying Jeff had gone too far
and he couldn't correct himself.
Yeah,
he had gone too far and he couldn't come
back and that's a real hard thing to
tell a person and it's a real hard thing
to tell a kid and they're the reason
why I left it that way. The
reason why I kept it like, listen,
you can make mistakes that you can't
come back from specially as a kid you can
make mistakes that you can't come
back from there. Pretty rare, right?
There's not too many mistakes that are
so grievous that you can't recover from
them. Like this guy, hey
man, he made a mistake,
failed a drug test given a general
discharge. That sucks. Guess what?
He can do all kinds of good in the world.
He can make up for that 10 fold.
He can start a business, make
money, he can create a family,
he can raise great kids and there's so
many things that he can make sure his
kids understand that and
know that and learn from it.
And he can make sure some
other neighborhood kids and
high school kids and grade
school kids, he can make such an impact
the world by learning from that mistake.
So it's very, it's a harsh
thing to say like, hey,
there's some things you can't now what
this guy can't recover from and this is
what the,
this is the fact that you have to face,
and this is why I told them
this way and the kid story,
he didn't understand when
he made that mistake,
he didn't understand that there are
some mistakes you cannot recover from.
He can't be a pilot now.
It's not going to happen.
Zero chance of him being a military pilot.
That's the way it works.
So if I would have had the opportunity
to tell him when he was 13 years old,
hey listen bro, I get it. You're going
to step outside the box sometimes,
but there's some mistakes that you can
make that you'll never be able to recover
from. So think about what
you're doing before you do them.
You need to think about what
And if I were to have the opportunity to
tell him that when he was 13 years old,
he might've had a better decision
making process when he got older.
That's why I left it that way for those
kids so that they recognize that there
are some things that you do
as a, as a person, as a kid,
that you cannot recover from. You
cannot recover from them. Hmm.
Now that being said,
when you take this and you put it in
perspective as an adult can, as an adult,
you have much broader
world to be a part of.
And just because he's not going to be
a pilot, a military pilot, by the way,
just because he's not
gonna be a military pilot.
There's all kinds of other
opportunities out there.
And you can explain that to an adult.
But it's hard to explain that to a kid.
So what other opportunities,
I mean you even if especially like,
oh you want to be a pilot, cool, you
can become a civilian pilot and you can,
you know, you can fly and you
can make things happen that way.
But what we're not going to do and what
I would not do is dwell on the past and
dwell on what the big missed opportunity
is. Because guess what? That's an,
that's a missed opportunity that there's
all kinds of people in the world would
love for that to be their biggest
mistake that they've made. That's the,
that's it.
They would love,
there's someone sitting in prison
right now that's like, man,
I wish all I did was get a fail a drug
test and I could have learned my lesson.
Instead I'm sitting here in prison or
I got injured really bad cause I did
something that I shouldn't have done or
I made a bad decision or I got someone
that I care about hurt or injured because
I took them in a car when I was drunk.
Like those are the kind of mistake, this
mistake. Sure. It's a bummer. Guess what?
There are infinitely, infinitely worse
mistakes that he could have made.
Infinitely worse.
So
you're all right, man.
You're okay. Learn from it.
Don't dwell on it. Move on and go, go do
something really positive in the world.
Yeah.
Next question.
Hey Jocko, what can we do with
a coworker who isn't on board?
When someone brings up something to him,
he gets defensive and turns it
into being everyone else's problem.
And this was a Twitter
question, by the way. And uh,
and I answered it and I answered it
really simply, really straight forward.
Take ownership of the
problem and solve it.
Take ownership of the problem and fix it,
right?
Because think about what's happening here,
right? What the person is saying like,
Oh, this is me saying, oh, echo
won't take ownership of the problem.
And every time I tell him
he does something wrong, he
just gets defensive, right?
So I'll, I'll, I mean obviously I'm
not communicating with you well enough.
If all I'm doing is blaming you and
you're getting defensive. And by the way,
if I'm the type of person that takes
ownership of things, why am I blaming you?
In the first place,
I should be looking at myself.
Okay?
I should be looking at my
stuff. And by the way, if Echo,
if you point your fingers at me
and you say, Hey, this is my fault.
You know what I say? Yeah, I agree.
It is my fault and here's what
I'm going to do to fix it.
Now I'm not going to rub it in your
face. I'm not gonna. I'm not gonna do it.
So I prove a point.
That's not what I'm doing.
I'm actually doing it because I want to,
when I'm actually doing it,
because I want to accomplish the mission.
That's why I'm going to fix the problem.
Hmm.
Now, if we have a weak member of the
team that doesn't take ownership thing,
guess what? It's my responsibility to
take ownership of the problem and fix it.
And eventually,
but the good thing about this is if you
make an excuse about something and I
fixed that excuse and then you make
an excuse about something else,
I fixed that one.
And then you make an excuse about
something else and I fixed that one.
Eventually.
There's no more excuses for you.
And now you're left with what you can
actually handle as echo with no more
excuses to make. And then either you're
capable, you're not in. By the way,
guess what,
as the leader,
then it becomes my job to
get rid of you if you can't,
if you cannot do the thing that I asked
you to do or that you're supposed to do
for the team. So yeah,
because I mean eventually if you,
if,
if I keep stepping up and
taking things away from you,
there's not gonna be any more excuses
and you'll either end up with no
responsibility and therefore no
value and then you have no job.
That's the way it works.
Now, let me ask you this.
When is there a time that a subordinate
does something and it's
not the leaders fault?
So,
so think about this.
W W E and when something goes
wrong with a team member,
when is it not the leaders fault?
So if you've got a machine gunner and
the machine gunner shoots outside of his
field of fire, clearly he didn't
pay attention during the brief.
That's the problem.
If I have a machine gunner that
engages non hostile targets,
it's the machine gunner his fault
because he didn't do improper.
He did improper positive identification
of its targets and engaged
a friendlies or,
or at least hostels.
So that's the machine goes wrong or the
machine gunners at weapon goes down.
Yeah
because the machine gunner didn't click,
it's his fault cause he didn't clean his
weapon, maintain his weapon properly.
The machine gunners fault.
So all those things,
the machine gunner shoots
out of his field of fire.
The machine gunner engages non hostile
targets and machine gunners weapon goes
down all those of the machine
gunners fault clearly.
Okay.
Or maybe not so clearly because here's
how I would look at those things.
Cause by the way,
when I point,
if you're my machine gun and I put my
finger at you and start yelling at you and
telling you that you did something wrong,
obviously we know what happens.
You start making excuses and
blaming other people and,
and you don't accepting responsibility
cause you get defensive.
And that's what people do.
So for me,
and what a good leader
does is a good leader.
When the machine gunner shoots out of
his field of fire, the leader says, Oh,
you know what? I didn't explain the
fields of fire clearly enough for you.
I'm sorry, I'll fix it. Machine
gunner engages on non-hostile target.
Then the leader says,
Hey,
I should have given you better
training on a target identification.
We will go back and fix that.
Yeah.
Or the machine gunners, a weapon goes
down. It means that I, as the leader,
you know what? I should've done
a better job inspecting weapons.
I should have explained how important
the maintenance was. That's my fault.
I won't let it happen again.
Okay.
So even in these instances where it's
real easy to blame the, the individual,
all good leader instead of blaming the
individual will take ownership of the
problem. That's what you do.
And that's what's going on.
In this case, you've got a
coworker that's not on board and,
and just gets defensive and turns it into
everyone else's problem. That's right.
Grab ownership of those problems.
And by the way,
that the subordinate that's
not taking ownership,
that's your fault as a leader and the way
that you get someone to take ownership
isn't by saying, Hey, don't get defensive.
You need to take
ownership of this problem.
It's your problem that doesn't
make people take ownership.
Here's the tricky part.
Here's the black belt situation.
The blackbelt situation is if I want
you to take ownership instead of blaming
you, I'm going to take, I'm going
to take ownership of the problem.
I'm going to relieve you of that and now
you're going to go way out. No, no, no.
With that, that the, no, I should
be able to fix that. I'm sorry boss.
I'm sorry Jocko.
I should have shot my,
I shouldn't have shot
outside the field of fire.
I need to pay better attention during
the brief if I don't know what it was.
I'm going to ask questions next
time. Are you sure? Yes, I'm sure.
Please let me get it fixed.
And that is how you get
someone to take ownership.
You don't get people to take ownership
by telling them to take ownership of
things.
And there's a little dichotomy here too
because if it's a plan than the way I
get you to take ownership of it is by
saying, hey, echo, come up with a plan.
Like we talked about
standard procedures earlier.
If I come up with a standard operating
procedures myself and then I forced him
onto you. You don't take ownership
of those. Yeah, those are mine.
So I have to give you ownership.
But when it's a negative it's when it's
a positive thing, I give it to you.
When it's a negative thing,
I take it,
I take it positive thing,
give it,
cause people want that positive thing.
When it's a negative thing,
they don't want it. You take
it from him and by the way,
when it's a positive thing
and you give it to them,
guess what they want to do with it. They
want to share it. They want to do it.
When it's a negative thing and you forced
on them, they want to get rid of it.
Okay,
so there you go.
I'm glad that this person's in the game
and now they know how to handle this
coworker and make it
into a good situation.
I think we've got time for one more
last question, Jacqueline. Hey Jocko.
How do you implement change
when you know it is needed?
How do you implement change when
you know what is needed to? Well,
when I know I need to change something,
what I do is I change it.
That's what I do.
I change it
and I've had people that listen to the
podcast and they've reached out to me
over the past few years and one of the
main messages that they took and put into
action was actually putting things
into action. Whatever that was, they,
they stopped eating sugar,
they stopped sleeping in,
they started waking up early.
They,
they quit playing video games
for 10 or 12 or 14 hours a day.
They sold that x box thing.
There was a guy that bit his nails for
his whole life and he's in his thirties
eh? Well, whatever. No big deals,
right? You know, he bit his nails. Well,
you know what,
his nails are all chewed up and they're
bloody and their gross looking at east
self conscious when he's meeting people
and shaking hands and he can't keep his
hands away from his mouth while he's in
meetings or in interacting with people.
But he couldn't stop
and then he stopped.
He just stopped and the list goes on.
There's people that have quit drinking.
I quit doing drugs and
quit losing their temper.
And I've heard from so many different
people that have implemented change in
their lives.
So,
so many letters and messages and notes.
And I want you to know that these people
aren't a bunch of of elite special
operations warriors.
That's not who they are.
They aren't a bunch of high level athletes
or highly screened in highly trained
individuals.
Okay?
These are just just normal people really.
But they're normal people that
knew they needed to make a change.
Okay.
And they decided they were going to
make a change and then they made it.
And that is what I do.
And that is what you can do too.
If you have something to change.
If you want to change something,
change it.
Change it
now.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight's.
So Echo.
Speaking of
implementing change and
change in our lives to
become a little bit better,
maybe you could help us with some things
that can make us sure. But better.
Sure. First, what's up with Mike in
the dragons, Mikey and the drugs. Yes.
So Mikey and the dragons is
okay
released into the world now.
Okay. So speaking of ownership,
and I know the one of the
earlier questions was about
ownership and I have to
take ownership myself at this
time because I made a mistake.
I made a mistake. And just
as I, as you pointed out,
as I've talked about my publisher not
ordering enough books and how, Hey,
they don't order enough books,
they don't get it. Well guess what,
I didn't order enough books.
So I am getting them printed right now.
I'm getting them printed as
fast as humanly possible. Um,
we have multiple printers
working and if you order early,
you're likely going to get
yours on the release date.
And I know some people had
been posting their Amazon, uh,
images that they're miking
the dragons is shipping.
So some people are going to get it soon.
Uh,
but even that's not a guarantee at
this point. Even if you ordered early,
I apologize. Don't blame
Amazon. It's not their fault.
Don't blame FedEx and don't blame the
post office and don't blame ups is not
their fault if you don't get the book
on time. It is one person's fault.
And that is mine.
I should have done a much
job of estimating how many
books you all were going to
buy.
And I guess as soon as I saw
people that were ordering 12 books,
12 miking the dragons, that should
have been real indicator that I,
that I should have gotten more printed.
But I didn't do that.
I apologize. Um, you
guys have ordered a ton.
And so this point,
I have a ton more being printed.
My goal is to get them
to you by Christmas.
It should be possible if you order now,
we've got enough coming in.
They should be there to get in
the stockings for Christmas if,
if you've already ordered. So if
you've ordered though, be patient. Um,
if you haven't ordered yet ordered like
right now so that I can print more.
And like I said right now we should have
enough, if you order right now, w you,
you should be able to get it by Christmas.
Um,
and if you want it,
yeah,
just order it and I'll just get as
many printed as we need. I apologize.
It's, it's definitely
my fault. I was weak.
I was, no, it was, I used to call
it week and then you'd be like,
they're just being conservative.
So I was too conservative.
I balanced it too much
in the wrong direction.
And so order the book and I appreciate
of the few people that I've sent a copy
to, the feedback has been
awesome. Um, the book in,
in the words of John Bozak who did
the drawing into the art and the,
you're going to see, he's the same guy
that did the art for way the warrior care.
This art is a totally different deal
because it's beautiful. It's color,
it's vibrant. Yeah. He did an amazing job.
Um, and you know what he says,
like he's, you know, he said to me,
he's like the annual people say things
and they say it in a certain way.
He did that. He just goes,
this book is special.
And I was like, you know, the way
he said it was like, I was like,
and I feel that way, but you
know, of course I'm biased
because I wrote it right.
But when, when he drew it, so he's biased
too, but he didn't say it like, Hey,
this book is awesome. Normal voice.
He was like, he was like, Hey,
this book is, this book is really
special. And I was like, okay.
So I think this book is going
to go in every kid's bookshelf.
I think it's going to be right next to
their copy of where the wild things are.
That's what I think, which was, you know,
all of our favorite book when you're a
kid. And I know that's a bold statement,
but anyways, I think it's gonna
have a great impact on kids.
So if you want a copy for your kids, for
your neighbor, kids, for your library,
your school, whenever
classrooms, um, for yourself,
for yourself. Yes. If
you're 38 years old, sure.
And you want to learn a little
something about the world,
about overcoming fear,
about how to face thing and you want to
have it put an IV in such a clear way,
then get yourself a copy.
So, right. Echo agree.
And you've read it. I
mean obviously, yes sir.
And you've read it to your youngsters.
Yes, I have. And they're approved.
Approved. Yeah. She wants me to
read it again. Well, this one,
this is a book that takes 20 minutes
to read. Yeah. Maybe 20 maybe.
I've been around 20 minutes to
read. Yeah. So it rhymes. Yeah.
Which is fun. Yes. And
impactful and little kids,
they love it. When those things
wrong, they follow it, they follow it.
So there you go. If you want one
again, I apologize if you're not,
if you don't get it on the 15th of
November, my goal is to add a minimum.
Some of you are going to get it on the 50.
If you ordered early,
hopefully you'll get it by then. But my
goal, let's get it to you by Christmas.
I've got publishers all over our
printers all over printing it.
So thank you.
And that's that Mikey and the dragons
order. Real quick, uh, what else? What
else do we need? Well, how else can we,
can we implement change in our life?
Sure. Well, led Jujitsu talk today.
Once you know the way broadly,
you will in fact see it as a thing.
So when you are exploring
the road of Jujitsu,
you're going to need a g. Even if you
do just know get well. If you don't,
if you only do Gnocchi
then I guess you don't.
But when you are searching for
ag, get origin g, that's it.
100%. Um, go to origin main.com.
That's where you get a rash guards in
there and just well all made in America,
woven in America, in America,
cotton, all the cock grown,
grown into American America woven in
America by the way. It's not just cotton.
Yeah, it's a special blend. And
especial we've bio a special we've,
how cool is that? We've
like, like no kidding.
When you see dragon we've for the first
time, why are you not like a little bit,
a little bit what? Impressed. Impressed.
So here's the thing too, when you,
when you kind of been in the
game for a long time, let's say,
you're not easily impressed by ds. No.
You, well, no. Yeah, no, not, not Jay.
Generally speaking. No.
But you do pay attention.
Like you know when you grab a geek,
your own gay,
you really used to your own gifts.
You have two gs,
three gs for Huggies and they're all
kind of different ways. You know those,
right? So when you see someone else with
the g, you grab it, you're like, okay, no,
I'm familiar, whatever. Cool.
But when you grab the dragon
weed for the first time,
especially when you've been in the
game for a while, you're like, Ooh,
this one is different.
Like, like that. Yeah.
Well I've definitely had a couple
people that only got into Jujitsu,
like they've only Dave
Burke. Good Dude. Yeah.
He's only had origin Giesen he's punches.
He doesn't even know what all
these other stories about bad games
like, oh, they just stink and
they're heavy and all the written,
all that stuff. He doesn't know any
better to be that. You're just like, oh,
everything is awesome in a way. I
mean, I kind of want to say, Hey Dang,
that's good for him. He's lucky
in that way, but you know, hey,
that's part of the game.
It's part of the journey nonetheless,
whether you use do it or not used to it,
dragging the weave is legit.
Are we allowed to talk about that new
weave that we were exploring the other day
at your house? Uh, not
yet. Okay. Do you have,
are we going to keep our beaks buttoned
on now on don't forget about rash guards
though. Yes, of course.
So when you're doing Nogi,
some people that use the tee shirt, I
dig it so they use a dry fit. I did it.
To me, rash guard is the
way to go. This is why,
because other people's toes sometimes
not all the time could get caught in that
shirt when it's flapping around in
the wind, but true. And you know, hey,
you know it's a rash guard. It's
cool. It looks more uniform. Me.
What about this scientific compression?
Increased vascularity on, I'm just
kidding. Hey Man, I'm sure there is.
There is that where the rash card when
you wear the compression clothing?
Yeah. Like health with after into
something like, and that's cool.
I'm not over here making those
plans. Yeah. I am making this claim.
19% improvement when you were the rash
guard based on your whole mental state.
Yes. Agree. Yeah.
And not to mention speaking to mental
state on those days that you don't want to
train, get a new rash guard.
Those days they don't exist.
Don't exist anymore for four months.
Then you did another new rash guard.
She'll give or take. It's true. So
yeah. Cool. The compression. Cool.
Cool. Yeah. Pete was actually starting
to go into it with me. Hey Man,
I could tell you, I'm like, well I'll
go man, let me call you back here.
We just go 19% and 19% based on
mental state getting after it harder.
Yes, I agree. So yes, some good
rash guards on there. Also some, uh,
well how should I say?
Lounge gear
that violates your whole thing that
violates everything lounge. Anyways,
that's the luxury.
You can call them luxury items.
You luxury Oh von here to talk about
luxury. Oh, just the concept of luxury.
Luxury, luxury days. Well the
sweats that they have are luxury.
And here's the thing, unprompted,
I go on Twitter and you know,
you get like people, when they get
their stuff, they're like, hey,
you mean you take a picture of
your stuff normal. So we've got,
we'll have a hoodie and he'll say,
this is the softest Hoodie I ever had.
That's the, that is the fact.
That is a fact. And then there's,
I didn't understand this joggers.
Yes.
I didn't understand why they're called
joggers and what their purpose is.
Old School sweat pants. Yeah. They're
just, there's like an elastic,
they're like straight cut than there's
elastic thing around the bottom of that
kind of stall baggy. Sure. The purpose
apparently did you tell me this?
That joggers are cut tighter and then
they have like a tighter ankle so you can
actually jog in them. That's the purpose.
So the group, I didn't know that.
I had no idea. So when you jog,
they don't flap around in the wind.
It's not just thankful the whole leg,
the whole leg kind of adheres to you.
It's more like fit into your leg and
then they're more roomy in the hips so he
can have a, you know, you can spray
it and jog. You can run seem sane.
They just so happen.
And that mobility that it allows for
running translates hundred and 10% to just
cruising.
When you're laying down on the,
I'm telling me hundred
percent take it from me.
I know there's some supplements
on there too. We've got some,
we got some supplements.
As a matter of fact. Um,
joint warfare number one bestseller,
joint warfare.
I see. Why a Krill oil. Yeah. What? Okay.
So a lot of people ask this too and
you told him, okay, the difference,
you know how the still guy would be like,
hey, I work a physical job eight hours,
10 hours a day.
I want to do a workout or wherever
my joints take kind of a beating.
What should I take? Joint
warfare or Krill oil. So people,
they will wonder about that.
Which one should I take?
Cause they're both for your joint
and the straight up answer is yes.
Take both of them.
You should absolutely take both of them.
If you can only get one.
If I would say if you're just,
if you're just feeling,
um,
what's the word?
Like if you have like legitimate soreness,
real legit soreness,
I would go with for warfare.
But I like Krill and I've thing is
I've taken the these things for so long
together that I just, I don't know. It's
hard for me to answer that. Yeah. Well,
Brian would tell me that
Krill oil is for just general,
you know, maintenance, you know,
you're getting, let's face it,
you're getting older and you got to
maintain it to maintain not getting old,
probably not and together. Yeah.
Like how you were saying, you know,
your drink to take a beating,
like a actual beating where
they kinda hurt now then yeah.
Joint Warfare Cause it helps inflammation.
Well actually the Krill oil I'll take,
I got fired,
I got fired up today.
I did my workout are through on the
weight vest. Oh yeah. And I just did,
I just pretended like I didn't have
it on but I had it on for my workout.
He probably, you know, that helps,
you know, mental state to be like,
so it's a difference between like, like
you can lift in these different ways too.
But yeah, when you put weights
on you just like, you know,
some people they'll swing a
baseball bat or something,
they'll put a weight on there, something
like that. And mentally if you,
basically you're training
your functionality with that
and that resistance sorta,
it just happens to be there. So your
brain just kind of accommodates, you know,
so when you function without the weight
to just flying around, it's like easy.
It's like I weigh less now,
you know, rather than an, Ooh,
I'm going to just eke out 10
reps of this very specific thing.
Then you're training your body.
I did Kinda did this little like a
mental debate, like, Oh, well, you know,
I feel like I should, I should do
something a little bit more. Oh,
maybe I'll do some rounds with this
and then I'll take it and they'll just
ignore. I'm just going to do
the whole thing. Like I just,
and I did every exercise, even just
completely unrelated exercises with,
with a weight vest on. Yeah, man, that's
good. I was doing box jumps the other day,
which I did, and I was like, man,
here's the warning on box jumps.
Pay attention during box jumps you,
it's real easy, especially when you get,
when you get smoked and
you start just kind of,
you're just going through the
motions and that's when you miss,
when you miss the box, jump
to get that Shinar no fun.
Yeah, yeah, no, and, and, yes,
and that's what I was thinking too. I was
like, man, when I could say, you know,
this is part of the metcon. I was going
back and forth. It's a long thing,
but Blackstone was part of it and yes,
towards those later rounds I was
like, okay, I'd better good. Yeah.
And I was doing it. I was adding a
little something, you know when you,
when you jumped down, I went down into
a little squat, then did the jump.
So it's not just the box, it's like
dumb squat ball anyway. But yes.
And made me think like,
Whoa,
I could get a weight vest and really
maximize the spa box jumps, pay attention,
pay attention. It takes some
discipline beforehand too, by the way,
which is a little pre mission.
Get some.
And then if you need food,
if you need nutrients for your body
and for your mind didn't take milk,
milk tastes delicious.
You know what I did yesterday?
I took whipping cream,
heavy whipping cream that you
turn into whipped whipped cream.
But normally what you put in it
know how to make whipped cream. Yes.
What do you do? Whip. It's super hard
to do at an egg white in it. Nope.
You got to add sugar. Oh, okay.
So recently I read this thing that one
of the whipped cream companies came out
with like Reese's peanut butter,
whipped cream and some other
kind of whipped cream. So
you get it in their spray.
Can you press the little nozzle?
Boom.
You got Reese's peanut butter
flavor, whipped cream. And
I thought to myself, Yup,
that sounds
boy that's the freedom part.
So guess what I did,
I took heavy whipping cream that you
make whip cream with and I put peanut
butter milk in it and I whipped it.
And guess what?
While la is good to go,
people like tastiness tastiness so yeah.
Uh, and all of them tastes great.
All of them are awesome for you.
And we got mint peanut butter, we have
meant chocolate, peanut butter, chocolate,
vanilla gorilla and of
course the darkness,
chocolate and then warrior kid,
Warrior kid milk of which look, they both
taste delicious. As a matter of fact,
my son today cause it was getting cold
and I hate saying that because we're in
California and cold is not cold.
So everyone in Michigan, everyone,
Pete the crew up in Maine, I apologize
cause it was getting cold this morning,
which meant it was probably
like 54. Yeah, right.
Which out here in California, in
southern California, it's like,
oh it was cold this morning. So
anyways, it was a little chilly.
This is more a little nip in the air of
course were only wearing shorts and a
tee shirt. So sure in Maine, I know
Pete's up there wearing a Parka,
but my son,
he was jumping on his bike
to go check the waves and um,
he had a little,
he had a little like a coffee tumbler,
one of our tumblers and he doesn't
drink coffee now. Kind of like what,
what are you doing? He goes,
I made some hot cocoa Mo.
And I said, let me try it with the
warrior. The warrior could talk.
It's just delicious. It's
just amazing. It's like, oh,
it's our cocoa except for guess what?
It's good for you. And makes you strong.
What's up with that? That's good.
What's up with that? So yeah,
that's the bulk anyways. Strawberries.
Delicious. It's get it for your kids.
It's in my house.
It seems to be the only thing anyone
in my house is eating right now.
So give that a shot and enjoy it.
You're going to be Matt.
I think he might be. What's a park? A park
is just a coat. It's a big winter coat.
Yeah. Yeah. You ever seen the coat
that has like a fur around the hood?
That's sort of like the
quintessential part Parka thing.
I think those things are kind of dope.
The word park is kind of kind of iffy.
What are you talking about? I don't
know. I've never heard the word.
I'm saying coming in fresh. You're
used to it, bro. You're from Hawaii.
How you to know where to park and not
even see snow until like three weeks ago
or something. No, for real. You didn't
see snow until you were 30 right?
Or something.
I'm like,
well technically I saw snow on the big
island when I was a little kid one time.
And you go to the big island,
you go up and Monica and you can see snow.
We went up there with shorts and a tank
top by the way, we just drove up there.
But since then, yes I had not
seen snow until I was 30. Yes.
So there's no possible way you're
going to know what a park is. So yeah.
So which kind of is part of my
point where if you've never really,
I mean I've heard the word Parker but I,
I'm not used to what kind of entails
and the and what the goodness of that.
So I'm just left with the word Parka
and a park is as far as just the word
doesn't seem like, uh, I dunno.
It seems like a funny word, Huh?
Well put some context around it.
Freezing cold people. Give them a Parka.
Nice functional Parka.
Be able to live. Yup.
Man. I dig it growing,
you know, if growth,
we call that grow up growing here
trying to, good speaking of growth,
you want to stay on the path and represent
at the same time grow in that way.
Go to Jocko store.com.
That's right.
Chuck was this door where you can get
your discipline equals freedom shirts,
women tank tops by way. Men,
tank tops, men's tank tops.
I know the temperature is dropping.
I'm not going to say it's
cold here in California.
I'm not gonna say that the
temperature is lowering. So I dig it.
If you're not going to wear the
tank top all the time, I dig it.
But they're on there
nonetheless. Uh, some hoodies,
either they're out now or they will
be within one week from right now.
T shirts,
tee shirts,
definitely see your presenting now stop.
Good.
Cause it's Eh,
I talked about like for me
to make a statement with what you're
wearing is kind of just a little bit,
I don't like that. It's too much.
I'm not dressing to make a statement.
I don't think,
I'm not dressing you make statement.
I wear the functionality is
primary. Sure. So I don't know.
I felt it was shirt is functional,
right? It is functional,
but it makes a subtle statement,
I must admit.
Well even when I was making the
statement is making a statement.
It's kind of like, well, no.
If you try too hard to not make a
statement and that's just, yeah, yeah,
then you're, you're a bigger state of
feeding it. Yeah. Defeating the purpose.
That's why this this shirt subtle
statement made in mostly to yourself.
Then on a statement to the world,
because people just look at this,
would not even think twice about it.
Maybe they think one more time about
it and think, what does that, well,
if you're watching this on youtube,
they're going to notice that you're not
wearing the victory and that's going to
be a huge statement and that's going to
actually maybe even throw some people
for a little loop nonetheless. Yes.
All on Jocko store.com some cool
rash guards on there as well.
Some get out a little bit more.
How should I say?
Geared towards the specific path
of kidding after the disaster,
technically one that
literally says get after it.
I guess that's point a.
Subscribe to the podcast.
If you don't iTunes Google play stitcher,
leave reviews so that we can read them
and get a good laugh from the crazy
things that you say. Thank you
all. So the warrior kid podcast,
we just put out a new one.
I apologize that they come a little
bit further apart than these. Uh,
I've gotten many people that have said
they had been listening to the first 18
warrior kid podcasts over
and over and over again.
So I'm glad there's are learning lessons
and I appreciate the feedback on those.
Also,
he'd go,
don't forget your warrior kid soap from
Irish oaks ranch.com young by made by
young warrior kid Aiden
who's making Jocko soap.
And his advice,
which I totally agree with,
is get some soap so you can
stay clean, dig it, Youtube.
Don't forget about youtube.
Subscribe to the Youtube Channel so
you can see echoes, legit videos.
You can see if we have guests on, you can
see who they are, what they look like,
how they react,
all that stuff you can get a feel for.
You can get to see what if you
don't know what Echo looks like,
he doesn't look like what he sounds like.
So we've been told so you can see what
echo looks like and then you can put a
comment that says,
it can say for instance,
Echo look in Jack,
sure or damn echoes Yo,
or whatever.
So there's a lot of those comments that
make it on there and I know that that
that's basically the form of compensation
that echo gets for his work is people
telling people than Youtube comments
saying echoes got jacked guns.
So if you want, if you want to pay Echo
Charles, if you want to pay Echo Charles,
there's no patriotic count.
There's no go fund me.
You just go onto youtube comments
and you right echo look and jack boy.
Oh, so there you go. Clever.
Also psychological warfare.
That's an album with tracks that
we made Jocko talking by the way,
telling you how to get past through,
get through power through those
moments of weakness when they arise,
which they do sometimes. By the way,
I know you didn't know this actually,
you didn't know this,
but they do a rise.
But if talk was there telling you
how to get through it pragmatically,
by the way,
you'll get through it.
I found that to be a fact a
hundred percent of the time.
Also while you're doing your
workout and it gets boring going on
at.com/chocolate by the way,
and get new kettle bells,
so what I did totally revives your
whole workout. In fact, do this,
do your normal workout if in fact it
doesn't have kettle bells in the workout.
Dude, your normal workout and
do a kettlebell like maybe
like a five or 10 minute
ones.
My son was asking me about working
out and he was kind of like,
well,
I just want to get like,
look what big muscles just just get
strong and so I and he can do or has done
the Kettlebell,
snatch
up the weight a little bit and
throw that thing up there and it,
I go every time you have to stop
that thing in the top position,
it's your whole body has to
kind of put some effort into it.
You will have if you haven't
done it before and you go
a little bit heavier than
like what you, which I don't, you know,
if it could be careful, blah blah blah,
whatever. Okay. So if you
go a little bit heavier,
you will have like sor abs or the
next day your abs will be sorting.
So your poster,
your chain sure will be some work.
Are you going to say it like that?
I know it's close to your posterior chain
because there's people like why don't
you want me to do, I can't, you know, so
your poster anterior chain will be uh,
get work. But believe it or
not, your front interior,
anterior chain, we'll get work
too because it has to arrest. Yes.
That weight, which is flying up
there and then asked to stop.
Otherwise it rips your shoulder out,
which is why you should be careful.
Don't go too heavy. And so
my, you know, my bicep is
this healing. It's almost
there man. We're almost there.
But one of the things I could straight
up not even start doing until very
recently is kettle bells on that
site. You know, cause it flaps around,
twist it, twist your wrist in
this way that it really, it puts,
so even when I go out on a light one,
and it's weird because the pain is less,
they're more so than just kind of the
raw newness of my arm going through that
whole kettle bell procedure.
See what I'm saying? So like,
you know when the thing comes up
to a rest right here on your wrist,
just it's sitting there on your wrist.
It has to rest there and your wrist,
your wrist is twisted in a
certain way, you know, it's cool.
It's normal if you don't. But man, it's
weird. The difference of my right hand,
my good hand and my bad hand. Just the
thing resting on the thing. It's like Ah,
you know how like do you have any,
so she lacked the conditioning. Yeah.
Faded just in your little
own. Yeah. Yeah. Tunnel.
The toughness of the email thing.
Yeah. Not that the other day when we
were rolling one, Oh that my toughness
dissension of tough.
Yeah. Yeah. No, no, no. I
didn't see it. I'll stay. I
was taking it light, you know.
See what I'm saying? You really,
you're really happy with that.
I'm just saying, Hey, don't
forget about Jocko white tea.
It is certified as the only beverage.
Whether you get it in the can are you
getting in the bag and you steep it
yourself.
Either way it is the only beverage in
the world that comes with a 100% money
back guarantee of an 8,000
pound dead lift. Good.
Which is really good and
it's organic by the way.
Panic on top of that.
Something so tasty and as the winter
arrives and it gets really cold.
California,
sorry,
my people of the north.
Do you get that warm tea going?
Just put a couple of bags. Now some people
worry about how long you should steep.
Do you know what steep the tea
means? I do not yet. Okay. Yeah,
so how long should you steep the tea
in my opinion, when I put a tea bag in,
it's not coming out straight. I just
leave it in there. I'm just going to,
I'm going to leave it in there. It's,
it's good to go to drink and you know,
like a couple, like a
minute, maybe two minutes,
but then I'm not taking that tea bag. I'm
going to get all that, all that Jocko,
White Tea, all that pomegranate,
goodness, all that, all,
all those antioxidants are coming right
into my system and it tastes delicious.
And it does have caffeine in it.
I will say.
So the cans have 60 milligrams
depending on how long you steep.
And I think when you steep it like I do,
there's probably a little bit extra,
a little bit of extra,
get some inside there.
Steve Gibbs also got some books. Okay.
Where the warrior kid and Mark's mission,
those are two kids books.
But I promise you that Uncle
Jake has lessons for everyone.
Yeah,
I agree. And I'm one of
those people. And uh,
so I think when you read that to
your kids, oh well in my case,
because my daughter is five, can't
quite read a book yet, so I'll read it.
But I feel like I'm reading to myself too.
Like these are all things that I,
some that you forget. I think as an
adult you forget a lot of these lessons.
You know, cause now you have a routine
as an adult, you have a routine.
Some of these lessons it feels like
they don't apply at first. You know,
so you kind of forget them and got,
man,
I wish I could just
incorporate that little thing.
One of the fundamental laws of combat is
simple and way the warrior kid is the,
it's the life rules put forth in a very
simple way that a young child could
understand them. But what's
surprising is in that simplicity,
it hits anyone solidly,
right between the eyes.
So that's way the warrior
kid and Mark's mission.
You can get those also about the
discipline equals freedom field manual.
That's another one that if you,
if you read or if you refer to,
it'll like remind you cause like,
okay, so man, I, I don't meditate.
I don't like, you know, like for like,
okay, it's arguable. What would you do?
Meditation, it's not,
it's not, it's not meant.
You know what they're talking about
when you said you meditate. So,
from what I understand,
if you meditate on certain things,
they help like incorporate it into your,
you know, your whole normal thought,
meditate or whatever,
he'll look over it.
That's what I would start with right
away. But, and then you would need,
and this is just my
thought about meditation,
you would need less reminders
of certain things, you know,
like how to like detaches
for whatever reason.
When I understood the concept of detach
and the importance of it, that's,
that's to me just kind of established
itself as like one of the most important
things that you can roll into your
life that will improve it right away.
Right then and there. But here's
the thing, just like you said,
you got to notice when you got to detach,
you know it's not,
detaching isn't the
hard part is to notice,
you know like when it's time to
go and so for lack of better term,
you're forgetting to detach right now
because you're so distracted by all the
feel or whatever. So it's one of the
few menu, it was like a really good one.
Select type men, if you
can refer to that, boom.
And this goes for all the subjects in
there by the way. Like, so like every day,
even every other day, two,
three days, whatever. Just
refer back to it, man. It helps.
It keeps it on your mind.
All these things only does people
post pictures of the field manual,
like one page or two pages.
And when I, whenever I,
when someone posts a picture of that,
I actually read,
I wrote the book but I still read this
section and say like, and, and it,
and I don't read it and go, oh, I
remember writing that. I actually go,
I can do that better. I want to do that.
I need to focus. You know what I mean? So,
and he was a good thing about
that word, overwhelmed, right?
That was the one that uh,
I don't even know who posted it at first,
but he was like on fraud posted
it and like JP, maybe g. Yeah,
like Andy Frisella. Yes. So
that was one where it's like,
you know why you don't, why people were
posting that? Because when they read it,
when they go, they referred to it,
they're like, oh I clicked again, let me,
you know, cause that's kind of the whole
nature of posting things. So the boom,
that's exactly what's happening. So it was
like boom, I need to remember that one.
It's not like that's the first time they
read it. Maybe it is, maybe it's not.
But most of the time it's like,
okay,
I referred back to that
and they get to repost it.
So it's doing exactly what I'm saying.
It's reminding you and the,
you know, certain ones apply to
you at certain times to, you know,
so it's like good man. Just to
refer back to that. So what I do,
it will keep you on the path.
If you want the audio version,
it's not available on audible.com
it's available on iTunes,
Amazon music, Google
play, other MP3 platforms.
Also extreme ownership.
I already talked about extreme ownership
and the leadership principles that are
in that and I talk about them all the
time and explain them to people in every
different type of organization. That's
what everyone had echelon front does.
Which is our leadership
consulting business,
which is me and Leif Babin and JP Denelle
and Dave Burke and Flint Cochran and
Mike's Rally and Mike [inaudible].
That's what we do.
We talk about the fundamental principles
that are in that book that we brought
home from the battlefield and
that book extreme ownership.
After we got done writing that book and
taught that stuff, we wrote another book.
It's called the dichotomy of leadership,
which we also talked about a bunch
of that cause you can't talk about,
you can't talk about leading human
beings without talking about extreme
ownership.
The fundamental principles
of the laws of combat and,
and then when you start
talking about that,
you've got to talk about
the dichotomy of leadership.
So those two books are also available.
And what I like seeing is
when I just saw one today,
guy had probably posted a picture of 30
copies of the dichotomy of leadership.
He's like,
yeah,
this is going to the whole team because
that's how you get everyone aligned.
You make everyone see, oh, you know
what? I'm going to think of this way.
Now some people go, oh, I don't
want to share the secrets.
They want to keep it for themselves. That
doesn't help you. You don't do better.
You do better if you,
if everyone understands the principles
that's going to make you do better as the
leader. And by the way, if you're out
there trying to do better for yourself,
don't read the book.
Go and do something else.
Cause I don't even want you
around just for yourself.
If you're just trying to look out for you,
the principles aren't for you.
You won't understand them
properly. So, and yet,
if you want to win, the best
possible way to win, by the way,
isn't by looking out for yourself. It's
by looking out for the good of the team.
It's by looking out for the mission.
That's how you win.
And that's what these
books will help you do.
So there's those Ashlyn front I already
talked about at leadership consultancy.
If you want us to come and work with
your company or come and speak to your
company,
go to Ashland,
front.com don't contact a speakers bureau.
Don't Google Jocko speaking because it
will be a random speaking agent that
you'll then have to work through.
Just contact us, our company, Ashland,
front.com
the muster,
we have monster seven and eight in 2019
check extreme ownership.com those are
our leadership conferences
and all of them have sold out.
Did I say some of them are sold out?
Nope.
All of them have sold out and they
are all going to continue to sell out.
So look for the details
when the opportunity,
when when we put the details out
and you want to come sign up,
that's extreme or soap.com and then
Overwatch is our business where we are
taking special operations leaders,
combat aviation leaders and placing them
into civilian organizations that need
leadership experience
and trained leadership.
So if you want to get involved with
that neat, whichever side you're on,
f overwatch.com go there and
you'll figure out which way to go,
whether you're someone from
our communities or you're
someone that needs leaders
from our communities,
go and make that happen.
And if you want to stay
on the path with us,
we are available on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on that page. Huh? Uh,
echo is at Echo Charles and I m at Jocko
Willink and thanks to all the military
personnel worldwide,
worldwide out there in harm's way holding
the line and here at home thanks to
police and law enforcement and paramedics
and he empties and correctional
officers and border patrol and first
responders. And at this moment actually,
especially the firefighters out here
fighting these crazy and powerful fires in
California,
thanks to you all are new.
There's a lot of police and mts and
paramedics supporting them as well.
Just all of you.
Thanks for risking your lives to make
us safer and to the rest of you that are
out there carrying on your mission,
whatever that may be.
But if you're listening,
I know you're in the game and trying
to get better just like we are and if
there's a change that you
need to make in your life,
you know what you need to do.
Okay.
Get after it and make that change.
You're done. Until next
time. This is echo and Jocko
out.